चलिए
सो आई थिंक वी आर लाइव
नाउ आई होप सो सो लेट्स सी चलिए चलिए चलिए
तो हम लाइव आ चुके
हैं वेलकम एवरी बडी वेलकम सबका स्वागत है
भाई सभी लोगों का स्वागत है स्वागत है
स्वागत है क्या हाल चाल है सबके कैसे हैं
आप
लोग बड़े दिनों के बाद हम मिल रहे हैं फिर
से दोबारा आज के बग बाउंट क्लास 20 में और
आज करने वाले हैं धमाका एज यूजुअल हर एक
क्लास की तरह राइट क्योंकि हर क्लास में
हम धमाका कर ही देते हैं तो मैं यहां पर
खुद का भी चेक अप कर लेता हूं साउंड एंड
ऑडियो का एक बार वेरीफाई कर लेता हूं एंड
सबको आ जाने देते हैं जल्दी से सभी लोग आ
जाइए भाई गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
सभी को गुड
इवनिंग सभी को गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते
चलिए हां जी तो यहां पर
लाइव चालू हो चुका है ओके 24 लोग आ चुके
हैं जल्दी आ जाइए सभी लोग आ जाइए फटाफट
फटाफट आ जाइए फटाफट आ
जाइए लाइक ठोकते जाइए लाइक ठोकते जाओ भाई
सभी लोग और क्या हाल चाल है
सबके सर एक रिक्वेस्ट है इतना गैप मत दो
अब क्लास ले लो गैप तो लगेगा गैप तो शं के
देना ही पड़ेगा बिना गैप का क्लास तो नहीं
पॉसिबल है क्योंकि द थिंग इज मल्टीपल
रीजंस है पहला यह कि काफी लोग नहीं कर
पाते अगर ज्यादा फ्रीक्वेंसी होती है तो
काफी लोग उसको कवर अप नहीं कर पाते उसको
कैच अप नहीं कर पाते क्लासेस को दूसरी ये
रीजन है कि लाइक और भी चीजें होती है उनके
साथ भी थोड़ा सा टाइम देना पड़ता है एंड
देन आपके लिए भी क्लासेस लेनी पड़ती है तो
सबको मैनेज करके चलना पड़ता है तो आपके
लिए मैनेज कर रहा हूं मैं एंड आई एम
ट्राइट प्रोवाइड यू द क्वालिटी कंटेंट एज
मच एज आई कैन
राइट
चलिए
बढ़िया तबीयत अब ठीक है तबीयत थोड़ी
गड़बड़ हुई थी बट बट अब सही है तबीयत राइट
एंड काफी कम लोगों ने अभी जवाइन किया है
ओनली 22 पीपल आर हियर सो आई
थिंक हमें और भी लोगों को आने देने का वेट
करना चाहिए क्योंकि काफी काफी कम लोग ने
जवाइन किया राइट एंड आई होप कि आप
एक्सएसएस के क्लासेस को फॉलो किया है आपने
एंड एक्सएसएस की प्रैक्टिस आप कर रहे हैं
आप में से कितने लोगों ने एक्सेसेस की
प्रैक्टिस की है प्लीज बताइए
मुझे जी हां सबको नमस्ते सबको नमस्ते सबको
गुड
इवनिंग
सब फ्री में बग बाउंट सीख रहे हैं अगर हम
सीख गए तो क्या हम सर्टिफिकेट मिलेगा कोई
सर्टिफिकेट नोटिफिकेशन नहीं मिलेगी भाई
कोई सर्टिफिकेट मिलने का कोई टेंशन नहीं
है कोई चांस नहीं है सर्टिफिकेट के लिए
थोड़ी सिखा रहा हूं भाई स्किल्स के लिए
लर्निंग के लिए सिखा रहा हूं स्किल्स लो
लर्निंग करो स्किल्स गेन करो ट्स इट
सर्टिफिकेट की कोई मतलब नहीं है कोई
वैल्यू नहीं है आपके
ओके चलिए काफी कम लोगों ने जवाइन किया है
50 भी नहीं हो पा रहे हैं
ना
चलिए मैंने वापस से एक बार अनाउंसमेंट कर
दिया ताकि सब लोगों को समझ में आ जाए
ओके सर एक्सेस करते हैं एटीएल इंजेक्शन
मिल गया बहुत बढ़िया बहुत अच्छी बात है
अगर एटीएल इंजेक्शन भी मिल गया कोई भी
टेंशन नहीं है सब मिल जाएगा सब बढ़िया है
सब बढ़िया आपको मिलेगा प्रॉपर भी मिलेगा
सब कुछ मिलेगा टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है
चलिए आज के सेशन में कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग करने
वाला
देखो आज की जो क्लास है उसमें हम क्या
पढ़ने वाले हैं
देखो आज की क्लास में हम ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस
को पढ़ने वाले हैं कुछ रिपोर्ट्स देखने
वाले हैं एक्सेसेस रिलेटेड क्योंकि
रिपोर्ट से आपको बहुत ज्यादा बेनिफिट
मिलने वाला है और मैंने पहले आपको बताया
हुआ था
कि यहां पे पहले मैंने आपको नॉन
परसिस्टेंट एक्सेसेस बताया था अब सोचोगे
कि नॉन परसिस्टेंट एक्सेस सर आपने बताया
नहीं इसको हम रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेस बोलते
हैं रिफ्लेक्टेड
एक्सेसेस इसी को बोलते हैं उसके बाद मैंने
आपको परसिस्टेंट बताया था परसिस्टेंट
एक्सेसेस जिसको हम स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस भी
बोलते हैं राइट स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस इसी को
हम बोलते हैं उसके बाद मैंने आपको डोम
बेस्ट का भी ओवरव्यू दे दिया था एंड अब जो
है आज की क्लास में वह हम ब्लाइंड करने
वाले हैं ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस ठीक है यह काफी
ज्यादा डेंजरस होता है और एक तरह
का टाइप ऑफ
परसिस्टेंट एक्सेसेस आप इसे बोल सकते हैं
ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस को अच्छा मुझे यह बताइए
आप
लोग सच सच बताइए थैंक यू विजय सिंह थैंक
यू आप लोग
प्रैक्टिस सच में करते हो कि नहीं करते हो
क्योंकि यार मुझे बहुत लोगों का
नहीं करोगे कोई बेनिफिट नहीं है भाई सच
बता रहा हूं अगर आप प्रैक्टिस नहीं करोगे
ना कोई फायदा नहीं मिलने वाला है
प्रैक्टिस जरूर आपको करनी है प्रैक्टिस
कीजिएगा उतना ही बेनिफिट है प्रैक्टिस
छोड़ दीजिएगा बेनिफिट नहीं मिलेगा बिना
प्रैक्टिस के बग बाउंट कुछ नहीं कर सकते
आप बग बाउंट में कुछ भी आपको माइलस्टोन
अचीव करनी है यू नीड प्रैक्टिस प्रैक्टिस
एंड प्रैक्टिस रेगुलर प्रैक्टिस जितना
प्रैक्टिस करोगे उतने चांसेस बनेंगे वैलिड
बग्स मिलने का बाउंटीज मिलने की रिवार्ड्स
मिलने का स्वैग्स मिलने का हॉल ऑफ फेम
मिलने का ये सब प्रैक्टिस के ऊपर है भाई
प्रैक्टिस मेक्स अ मैन बेटर अ वमन बेटर बग
बाउंट हंटर मैन या वमन कोई भी हो अगर
अच्छा हंटर बनना है तो आपको प्रैक्टिस
करनी
है ठीक
है सर दो-तीन दिन के लिए क्लास पोस्टपोन
कर दो बताओ अभी शांके बोल रहा था सर गैप
मत दो कुछ बंदे बोलते हैं सर क्लास
पोस्टपोन कर दो मतलब और भी गैप दे दो ये
यार थोड़ा सा वो है लेकिन क्लासेस चलेंगे
ऑलरेडी बहुत दिनों का गैप हो चुका है आपको
पता ही होगा चार चार दिनों का गैप लगभग हो
चुका है हमारा इस और प्रीवियस सेशन के बीच
में बहुत ज्यादा गैप दे दिया था आई होप कि
आप सबने कवर अप किया है एंड अगर आप यह
वीडियो देख रहे हो या जो भी वीडियोस देख
रहे हो आपको मैं रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि बग
बाउंट की डे वन क्लास वन से आपको वीडियो
देखनी है और पूरी वीडियोस देखनी है बग
बाउटी की प्लेलिस्ट में जाके एंड देन आपका
सब कुछ क्लियर होता जाएगा आपको कोई टेंशन
नहीं लेनी बग बाउटी कहां से कैसे करना है
कैसे स्टार्ट करना है कि सब कुछ कवर किया
गया है डेज में ठीक है सर जी बहुत गैप हुआ
हां जी हां जी वही मैंने बोला कि बहुत
ज्यादा गैप मैंने ऑलरेडी दे दिया हुआ था
राइट ओके डिस्कार्ड ग्रुप ओके देखते हैं
चलिए तो अब ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस के ऊपर आते
हैं एंड अगर आप लोग प्रैक्टिस नहीं कर रहे
आप लोग प्रैक्टिस कीजिए प्रैक्टिस के बिना
भाई सच बता रहा हूं कोई फायदा नहीं होने
वाला है कोई बेनिफिट आपको नहीं मिलने वाला
है अगर आपने प्रैक्टिस नहीं की याद रखिएगा
बिना प्रैक्टिस का कुछ नहीं
है
चलिए सर एसकल इंजेक्शन के ऊपर भी वीडियो
बनाओ अरे भाई आएगा टेंशन क्यों ले रहे हो
इतना टेंशन लेके क्या फायदा चलो अब
ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस के ऊपर आते हैं अब देखो
ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस क्या है पहले इसको समझते
हैं एंड देन आगे हम बढ़ते हैं देखो तुमने
जब रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेसेस पढ़ा था क्या हुआ
था रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेसेस के केस में मैं
यहां पे ओपन कर लेता हूं यहां पे टेस्ट
ph.com आई होप डिसेबल कर देता हूं मैं बब
शूट को टेस्ट पीप web.com ठीक है
रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेस के केस में क्या हुआ
था मैं यहां पर एक पेलोड उठा लेता हूं
लेट्स ओपन अ पेलोड कोई से भी पेलो उठा
लेते
हैं एक सिंपल पेलो
हमने य
वाला एक सिंपल पेलोड हमने उठाया यहां हमने
पेलोड डाला एंड यहां पर हमने गो प क्लिक
किया जैसे ही गो प क्लिक किया यहां हमें
एक रिफ्लेक्शन आ गई हमें एक क्या पॉप अप
मिल गया एंड यह पॉप अप जो है वो हमें यहां
पर इस पेज से मिल चुका तो ये हमने चेक देख
किया था हमने रिफ्लेक्टेड एक्सेस केस में
देखा था स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस के केस में भी
आप कुछ इस तरीके का काम कर सकते हैं जैसे
मैं कैटेगरी पर गया यहां गया
थैंक यू आरसी टेक यहां गया नेम मैंने डाला
यहां पर अपना पेलोड एंड यहां पे डाला एंड
यहां पे सबमिट करा जैसे सबमिट किया हमें
यहां पे एक पॉप अप आ गया एंड दिस बिलोंग
टू द स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस क्योंकि हमने एक
कमेंट किया जो कि एक वेब एप्लीकेशन से
इंटरेक्ट कर रहा है एंड कहीं ना कहीं
स्टोर हो रहा है एंड देन वी गट द पॉप अप
एंड ये स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस में कन्वर्ट हो
चुका अब बात कर रहे हैं ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस
की ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस की जब हम बात करते
हैं इसका मतलब है ब्लाइंड एक्सेस की जब आप
बात करते
हैं यू सी
नथिंग ठीक है यू सी नथिंग आप कुछ नहीं देख
रहे हो
धन्यवाद क्या
हुआ दिस इज द बेस्ट वीडियो ऑन बग बाउंडी
थैंक यू
जस्ट अ सेकंड
गाइ ओके आप लोगों की एक बार चैट देख लेता
हूं
मैं
अ ओके
ओके आपकी वीडियो देखकर चाइनीज वेबसाइट के
एडमिन पैनल ब्रूफोर्स करके लॉग इन कर लिया
क्या बात है भाई बहुत बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया बहुत शानदार अभी पता है अभी लिन पे
दिखाता हूं तुम लोगों को
देखो यहां पे
एक्टिविटी प चलते हैं मैं आपको एक चीज
दिखाता हूं तबीयत तब ठीक है सो यहां पे एक
बंदे ने हमें टैग किया था एंड इस बंदे को
यहां पे आई एम एक्साइटेड टू शेयर द फर्स्ट
डिस्कवर द फर्स्ट बग ऑफ 2024 एंड इन्होंने
हमें मेंशन किया तो हमें पता चला कि यहां
पे इसको इस बंदे को यहां पे बेसिकली हॉल
ऑफ फेम मिला हुआ है एंड ही गॉट हिज फर्स्ट
बग राइट सो
दैट्ची हमने फिर यहां पे कमेंट भी किया
हुआ था इनको ठीक है तो ऐसे ही आप पोस्ट भी
कर सकते हैं चलिए अब यहां पे
गाइस ब्लाइंड एक्सेस में हमें कुछ नहीं
दिखता है यू सी नथिंग मतलब अब सोचो कि
आपने एक अपने टारगेट के ऊपर यहां पेलो
डाला एक्सेसेस की और आपको कुछ दिख ही नहीं
रहा ना तो पॉप अप दिख रहा है कुछ भी नहीं
दिख रहा कैसा लगेगा ब्लाइंड हो गया ना
बिल्कुल अंधा यह होती है ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस
मतलब कि ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस में क्या होता
है यू इंसर्ट
योर पेलोड एनीवे
वेयर लाइक
इन कमेंट
बॉक्स साइन अप
फॉर्म्स कांटेक्ट
फॉर्म्स फीडबैक
फॉर्म्स
रेफरर रेफरर रेफरर में भी आप अपने डाल
सकते हैं याद रखिएगा रेफरल जो हेडर है
आपका स्पेलिंग देख लेना जो भी स्पेलिंग है
रेफरल हेडर डाल सकते हैं आप होस्ट हेडर
में डाल सकते हैं आप अ इन फैक्ट यू कैन
आल्सो ऐड दिस इन
ओरिजिन ओरिजिन हेडर एंड यूजर एजेंट
हेडर आप इन सब जगहों पे भी एंड एनी
पैरामीटर एनी
पैरामीटर्स ठीक है तो आप अपने ब्लाइंड
एक्सेसेस के पेलोड इन किसी भी जगह पे डाल
सकते हैं और उसको मॉनिटर करना है अब मान
लो आपने क्या किया आपने क्या किया मैं एक
एग्जांपल के तौर पे समझ लो ठीक है एक
एग्जांपल के तौर पे आपको समझाता हूं लेट्स
सपोज आपने एक बंदे को कोई एक चिट्ठी दी
ठीक है बोला यह लेटर को उस जगह पे पहुंचा
देना है डिलीवर कर देना है ठीक है अब आप
उस बंदे को ट्रैक कर रहे हो कि मुझे जब
लेटर डिलीवर हो जाए तो मुझे भी पता चल जाए
कि एक्चुअली उसने लेटर डिलीवर कर दिया है
क्योंकि वो बंदा आपको बताने नहीं जा रहा
वो बंदा आपको आके दोबारा रिवर्ट नहीं करने
जा रहा कि भैया मैंने लेटर वो पहुंचा दिया
है उसका काम है लेटर लेके जस्ट पहुंचा
देना तो आप उसको ट्रैक कर रहे हो उस बंदे
को कि भैया मुझे पता चल जाए कि वह लेटर
पहुंच चुका है अपनी जगह पर सेम वही बात है
यहां पर आप जब पेलोड ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस
पेलोड की जब बात करते हैं यहां पे तो आपने
ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस की पेलोड डाल दी यह पलट
कुछ भी हो सकता है आपकी जो नॉर्मल
एक्सेसेस पेलोड्स है ना वह भी हो सकता है
बट वह इंटरेक्ट कर रहा होगा किसी ना किसी
तरीके से आपके थ्रू एंड आप तक वो
पहुंचाएगा कि भैया आपने जो पेलोड डाला था
उस जगह पर वह
इंटरेक्ट आपसे कर रहा है ऑलरेडी एंड वो
एग्जीक्यूट हो चुका है ठीक है अब वो
एग्जीक्यूट कहां होगा वो एग्जीक्यूट होगा
ऑन सेम
प ऑन एडमिन साइड और
ऑन एनी अदर
एप्लीकेशन ठीक है सिंपल ऑन एनी अदर
एप्लीकेशन यहां पर एग्जीक्यूट होगा अब
इसका मैं एक एग्जांपल आपको बता बताता हूं
जैसे कि मान लो एक कोई वेबसाइट है कोई भी
वेबसाइट है जैसे मैं क्या करता हूं बग
क्राउड प चलता हूं लेट्स ओपन बग
क्राउड यहां पे कोई भी एक प्रोग्राम चूज
कर लेते हैं लेट्स चूज एनी ऑफ द प्रोग्राम
यहां पे चल देते हैं प्रोग्राम्स पे ठीक
है चलिए यहां पे प्रोग्राम्स पे आ गए आई
थिंक मुझे री ऑथेंटिकेट करना
पड़ेगा ठीक है तो मैंने ऑथेंटिकेट कर दिया
एंड यहां से कोई भी एक प्रोग्राम चूज करते
हैं कोई भी एक लाइव प्रोग्राम चूज करते
हैं जिसमें हम ये चीज करेंगे ट्राई करेंगे
करने
का ठीक है सो वी गट इट वी गट हियर एंड
यहां पर हमने रैपिड यह वाला जो प्रोग्राम
है इसी को चूज कर लेते हैं लेट्स ओपन द
रैपिड हमने रैपिड को ओपन कर
लिया यहां पर आते हैं एंड यहां पे कोई सा
भी इनका एक जो टारगेट है हम चूज कर लेते
हैं जैसे रैपिड नेट है तो चलिए रड नेट जो
हमारा टारगेट है इसी को सिलेक्ट करते हैं
इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं ड नेट को लेट्स ओपन
इट ये हमारा टारगेट है हमने यहां पे कर
लिया अब मान लो मुझे कांटेक्ट सेल्स का
ऑप्शन है यहां पे कांटेक्ट सेल्स प आते
हैं एंड यहां पे एक कांटेक्ट फॉर्म है ठीक
है हियर इट इज अ कांटेक्ट फॉर्म अब मुझे
इस कांटेक्ट फॉर्म में क्या करना है मुझे
यहां पे ऐड करनी है अपनी एक्सेसेस ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस पेलोड्स अब ये ब्लाइंड एक्सेस
पेलोड्स कहां से आप ले सकते हैं किस तरह
का पेलोड होगा तो देखो दो तरीके हैं दोनों
तरीके का आप यूज कर सकते हो एक तो
आप ऑनलाइन टूल एक आता है या मल्टीपल टूल्स
है आप उसका यूज कर सकते हो जैसे कि हम बी
एक्सस की बात कर रहे बी
एक्सस बी एक्सस इसकी हम बात करें हम इसका
यूज कर सकते हैं सेकंड नंबर पर यहां पर हम
बर्ब कोलबो कालेबोरेट का यूज कर सकते हैं
वी कैन यूज बर्ब कोलबेट आल्सो अब देखो
यहां पर कैसे ऑनलाइन टूल बी एक्सस की मैं
बात कर रहा हूं य पर कौन से बी एक्सस की
मैं बात करर यहां पर मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं दिस टूल सो लेट्स ओपन बी एक् बी
एक्सस हटर इसको ओपन कीजिएगा ये वेबसाइट
ओपन हो जाएगी b एक hunter.com यहां पे आप
आ जाइएगा यहां पे आने के बाद आपको लॉग इन
कर लेना है लॉग इन का नहीं मतलब साइन अप
पहले कर लीजिएगा रजिस्टर कर लीजिएगा यहां
पे ईमेल फोन नंबर जो भी है डालना है
रजिस्टर कर लीजिएगा फिर लॉग इन कर लीजिएगा
ठीक है तो मैं यहां पे लॉग इन कर लेता हूं
आई थिंक मुझे पासवर्ड शायद याद
होगा सो लेट्स लॉग इन यहां पे ये लॉगइन इस
तरह हो जाएगा लॉगइन कर लेंगे तो आप यहां
पे आएंगे यहां पे आपको एक्सस के पेलोड्स
मिल जाएंगे कुछ प्री डिफाइंड पेलोड्स मिलल
जाएंगे अलग-अलग सिनेरियो के लिए जैसे
जावास्क्रिप्ट य आरआर वेयर यूजर्स अ यू
आरआर टेकन एज़ अ इनपुट यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट
टैग पेलोड बेसिक एक्सेस पेलोड आपको यहां
पे यह मिल जाएगा बेसिक पेलोड है यहां पे
तो आप इसको भी ले सकते हैं यहां पे आप जो
भी आपने नेम दिया होगा साइनअप के टाइम पे
उसी का एक बेसिक सब डोमेन बन जाता है आप
उसको यूज़ कर सकते हैं अब मैं क्या करूंगा
मैं इस सिंपल बेसिक पेलोड को यहां से कॉपी
कर लूंगा यह पेलोड कॉपी हो गई अब मैं अपने
टारगेट पे फर्स्ट नेम में पेलोड डाल दूंगा
लास्ट नेम में यहां पेलो डाल दूंगा यहां
पे कंपनी नेम यहां पे पेलोड ही डाल दूंगा
कंपनी ईमेल आईडी मैं कुछ भी डाल देता हूं
अ जैसे हेलो @ h.com ये डाल दिया कंट्री
मैंने यहां पे इंडिया डाल दी यहां पे पूछ
र है ये ओरिजिनल मेल डालने का तो चलो मैं
यहां पे टेंप मेल यूज कर लेता हूं लेट्स
सी टेंप मेल अगर ये कंसीडर करते हैं या
इन्होंने फिल्टर कर दिया है लेट्स
सी तो मैंने यहां पे टेंप मेल ओपन कर लिया
एंड यहां पे मैं इसको कॉपी करके यहां पे
ऐड कर दूंगा सिंपल
सो लेट्स कॉपी इट ए आई होप कि ये ले ले
ठीक है ले लिया नंबर फोन नंबर मांग रहे
है हमने फोन नंबर डाल दिया यहां पे बिजनेस
का वो डाल दिया हाउ कैन य हेल्प यू इसमें
भी हमने क्या किया हमारे एक्सस का पेलो
डाल दिया ठीक है वी इंसर्टेड द ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस पेलो अब यहां प ब्लाइंड एक्सेस
पेलोड का डाल दिया यहां पे अब देखो क्या
होगा जब मैं ये कांटेक्ट फॉर्म सबमिट
करूंगा तो हो सकता है मेरा पेलोड अभी
ट्रिगर ना हो और पॉप अप ना आए ऐसा हो सकता
है बट ऐसा हो सकता है जैसे ही हमने यह
कांटेक्ट फॉर्म फिल किया इस कंपनी के
एडमिन पैनल के साइड कोई मान लो एक टेक टीम
है या कोई एक लाइक बैक ऑफिस टीम है या तुम
जो भी टीम बोल लो सेल्स टीम है सपोर्ट टीम
है जो इस कांटेक्ट फॉर्म को रिव्यू करती
है या ओपन करती है पढ़ने के लिए ठीक है कि
भाई कौन-कौन सी कांटेक्ट फॉर्म में
क्या-क्या एंट्रीज आई है कौन-कौन से लोगों
ने कांटेक्ट हमें किया है बस इसके लिए एक
बैक एंड में टीम है वो उनका काम है
कांटेक्ट फॉर्म्स को एनालाइज करना उनको
पढ़ना अब जैसे ही वो उस कांटेक्ट फॉर्म को
ओपन करते हैं आपका एक्सेसेस फायर हो जाता
है एंड आपको आपके इस टूल के अंदर में जब
आप यहां पे जाएंगे एक्सेसेस फायर्स के
अंदर में तो आप जब इस पे जाएंगे तो आपको
यहां पे लिस्ट मिल जाएगी कि भैया यहां पे
पर्टिकुलर एक्सेसेस फायर हुआ है मैं यहां
पे कुछ ये फाय एक्सेसेस जो है इसको मैं
डिलीट कर कर देता हूं ताकि आपको फ्रेश दिख
जाए जस्ट
वेट पता नहीं यह यहां से हट भी रहा है कि
नहीं ठीक है इस तरीके से ये ठीक है चलो
रहने दो ये दूसरे यूआरएल से कोई बात नहीं
हम यहां प देख लेंगे अब मैं य क्या करूंगा
यहां पर मैं सबमिट करूंगा ठीक है
दैट्ची
यहां पर लोड कर देंगे अब हम अलग-अलग यहां
पर पेलो को आपको टेस्ट करना पड़ेगा जरूरी
नहीं है कि यह पेलो एक्जिक्यूट होई फायर
होई बैक एंड में ठीक है तो कहने का सेन यह
है कि इसको मैं वैसे समझा देता हूं ऑनलाइन
वाइट बोर्ड ठीक है मैं इसको ऐसे समझाता
हूं ताकि आपको और भी अच्छे से समझ में आ ग
आ जाए
देखिए यहां पर कंपनी का क्या है कांटेक्ट
फॉर्म
है
कांटेक्ट फॉर्म है यहां पर यह क्या
है हैकर है
अपना ठीक है अब इस कांटेक्ट फॉर्म में
हैकर ने क्या किया यहां पर ब्लाइंड
एक्सेसेस पेलो डाला यह मैं माउस से ड्र कर
रहा हूं तो इसलिए य इस तरीके का आ रहा है
यह दिख रहा आपको टेंशन नहीं ली ठीक है
ब्लाइंड एक्सेस का पेलो डाला अब यह
कांटेक्ट फॉर्म को कंपनी के यहां
पर
मैं यहां पर ऐसे करता
हूं
कंपनीज सपोर्ट
टीम यहां पर कंपनी के जो सपोर्ट टीम है
इसको क्या कर रही है यह एनालाइज कर रही
है
इसको एनालाइज कर जैसे ये एनालाइज कर रही
है मान लो इन्होंने इस कांटेक्ट फॉर्म को
एनालाइज किया वैसे ही हमारा क्या हो रहा
है एक्सेसेस क्या हो रहा है फायर हो जा
रहा है यानी ट्रिगर हो जा रही है जैसे ही
ये ट्रिगर होगी ठीक है राइटिंग पैड है यार
मेरे पास लेकिन अभी बस इससे कर रहा हूं
ठीक है जैसे ये ट्रिगर होगी हमारे पास
यहां पे एक्सेस फायर्स के अंदर में ये
यहां पे डिटेल आ जाएगी एंड यहां पे ये फाय
आपका यहां पे शो होने लगेगा ठीक है अभी
फिलहाल हमारा कोई फायर नहीं हुआ है इट
मींस वी आर नॉट गेटिंग एनी फायर एंड हमारा
ये पेलोड फायर नहीं हुआ है अब ये चीज आप
ना टेस्ट कर सकते हो दूसरे पे लोट्स के
लिए ठीक है दूसरे पे लोट्स के लिए भी जैसे
मैं इसको अभी फिलहाल डिलीट करता
हूं तीन बचे हैं
एक
दो एंड यहां पे तीन ठीक
है तो हमने ये किया एंड यहां पे एक्सेस
फायर्स प चलते हैं अभी कोई भी फायर नहीं
हुआ है क्योंकि हमने यहां पे डाला बट
हमारा कोई भी फायर नहीं हुआ यानी कि वहां
पे एक्सेस हमारा वो अवेलेबल नहीं है अब हम
यहां पे सेम कांटेक्ट फॉर्म को रीलोड
करेंगे मान लो यहां पे और यहां पे अब कोई
एक और पेलोड कोई दूसरा पेलोड हम ट्राई
करेंगे यहां पे इंजेक्ट करने का ठीक है
कोई भी दूसरा पेलोड हम यहां पे इंजेक्ट कर
सकते हैं एंड फिर हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं
जैसे मान लो मैंने क्या किया यहां पे मैं
ओपन कर लेता हूं अ टेस्ट पीएचपी टेस्ट
पीएचपी यह वाली मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं हमारी
ठीक है लेट्स सी ये मैंने ओपन किया मैं
यूजर प्रोफाइल पे चल देता हूं अ यूजर
प्रोफाइल पे चलते हैं यहां पे मैं टेस्ट
टेस्ट लॉगइन कर लेता हूं यहां से सिंपल
लॉग इन कर लिया मैंने ठीक है अब मैं क्या
करता हूं यहां पे मैं यहां पे नेम में
यहां पे अपना एक फ जो हमारा पेलोड है वो
एंटर कर देता हूं ठीक है जैसे यह वाला
पेलो डी मैंने कॉपी कर
लिया लेट्स गो हियर नेम पैरामीटर में
मैंने ये पेलो डाल दिया ठीक है बाकी में
क्रेडिट कार्ड में कुछ मैंने कुछ भी डाल
दिया यहां पे ईमेल आईडी में लो @
hello.com डाल दिया फोन नंबर में मैंने भी
कुछ भी डाल दिया एंड एड्रेस में हेलो
एड्रेस ये डाल दिया पेलोड नहीं डाला मैंने
ये वाला चीज किया अब मैंने क्या किया यहां
पे ये करके मैंने यहां पे अपडेट पे क्लिक
कर दिया जस्ट इट जैसे ही मैंने अपडेट पे
क्लिक किया हमें यहां पे कुछ ऐसा कुछ
रिजल्ट आया बट हमें कोई पॉपअप नहीं आई अब
हम अपने एक्सेस हंटर वाले पेज पे चलते हैं
यहां पे एंड एक्सेसेस फायर्स पे चलते हैं
जैसे ही मैंने एक्सेस फायर्स पे क्लिक
किया यहां पे आपको आपको दिख रहा होगा कि
वी गॉट अ फायर हमें एक फायर मिल गई है एंड
यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं कि स्क्रीनशॉट
यहां पे है बट स्क्रीनशॉट ये आया नहीं है
ठीक है वल्नरेबल यूआरएल ये वाला यूआरएल
यूर info.php जो यूआरएल हमने यहां पे ओपन
करके रखा हुआ था ठीक है यूजर इंफो वाली जो
यूआरएल थी ओबवियसली कहां गई टेस्ट पीएचपी
वाली अ ये रही यूर info.php ये वल्नरेबल
यूआरएल है अब यहां पे जब आप शो मार्क डाउन
पे क्लिक कीजिएगा ये विक्टिम की आईपी है
ये वाली आईपी ये आईपी हां ये आईपी जरूर
चेक कीजिएगा आईपी वेरीफाई जरूर कीजिएगा
बिना वेरीफाई किए आई फिर दिक्कत हो जाएगी
आपको अगर आईपी उसी पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम की
है उसी आईपी से अगर आपको ट्रिगर मिल रहा
है तभी जाके कोई बेनिफिट है तभी आपका वो
एक्सेप्ट होगा बक बाउंडी प्रोग्राम में जब
आप रिपोर्ट कर रहे होते हैं तो ठीक है अदर
वाइज नहीं एक्सेप्ट होगा कोई मान लो किसी
थर्ड पार्टी ऐप से आ रही है जैसे क्या
होता है कि तुमने पेलोड डाला अब यह पेलोड
उस पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम के किसी बैक एंड
टीम से आ सकती है एडमिन कंसोल से आ सकता
है या तो किसी थर्ड पार्टी पप से भी आ
सकता है तो थर्ड पार्टी ऐप से अगर आ रहा
है अगर वो उनके स्कोप में नहीं होगा तो
तुम्हें बाउंट नहीं मिलेगी बट अगर स्कोप
में होगा तो मिल जाएगी तो यहां पे सिंपल
सा मुझे इसी की आईपी चाहिए आईपी उसी की है
तो यहां पे आप शो मार्क डाउन पे आप क्लिक
कीजिएगा यहां पे तो आपको पूरी डिटेल जो है
आपको इस पर्टिकुलर आपने जो पेलोड यूज किया
है उसके आउटपुट से रिलेटेड सारी डिटेल
आपको मिल जाएगी जैसे आप देख सकते हैं t
ph1 web.com यहां पे आपको एक कुकीज यहां
पे मिल जाती है लॉगिन अ ये वाली कुकी जो
है ये आपको मिल जाती है ब्राउजर एजेंट
आपको मिल जाता है ठीक है यहां पे आईपी
एड्रेस मिल जाती है प्रोब आईडी मिल जाती
है यहां पे एक जो आपको करके मिलता है ठीक
है सीआरएस की हेडर्स की मिल जाती है गिट
एक्सपोज कोई गिट डायरेक्ट एक्सपोज है वो
मिल जाती है ठीक है यहां पे रेफरर हेडर जो
है आपको वो मिल जाता है राइट यहां पे अब
यहां पे नीचे आते हैं यहां पे ये सोर्स
कोड आपको मिल जाता है तो बेसिकली आप सोर्स
कोड में कंट्रोल एफ करते हैं मैं यहां पे
फनि सर्च करता हूं तो हमारा ये पेलोड था
आप यहां पे देख सकते हो स्क्रिप्ट एआरसी
वो भी आपको यहां पे सोर्स कोड में दिख
जाता है जिसका यूज करके आप बेसिकली अपनी
रिपोर्ट राइटिंग के लिए रिपोर्ट तैयार
करने के लिए आप इसका यूज कर सकते हो इसका
इस्तेमाल कर सकते हो एज सिंपल एज दैट ठीक
है तो आपका उसमें भी हेल्प हो जाएगा उसके
बाद यहां पे आप बैक बैक पे मैं जाता हूं
यहां पे देखो दो बार ये दो एक दो तीन तीन
बार यहां पे फायर हो चुका है ये तो व्हाट
आई एम डूइंग आई एम जस्ट गेटिंग आउट ऑफ दिस
ठीक है यहां पे ये तो आपका ये आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा जैसे अब मैं यहां पे क्या
करूंगा कलेक्टेड पेज पे जाएंगे तो यहां पे
कोई पेज अगर कलेक्ट हुआ रहेगा तो आपको
यहां पर यह दिख जाएगा बाकी तो आपको
डैशबोर्ड प चलेंगे तो आपको यहां पर दिख
जाएगा कि एक्सेस फाय कितने हुए टोटल यून
टारगेट्स कौन से हैं ये आपको दिख जाएगी
एंड नेक्स्ट इ जनरेट मार्क डाउन प क्लिक
कीजिएगा तो यह एक मार्क डाउन क्रिएट हो
जाएगा बेसिकली क्या है यह एक रिपोर्ट है
तो यह आपके लिए बहुत बेनिफिशियल हो जाएगा
यहां पर आपको एक रिपोर्ट मिल जाएगी ठीक है
यू विल गेट द
रिपोर्ट आवाज नहीं आ रही है कैसे नहीं आ
रही आवाज आवाज नहीं आ रही है क्या गाइस
जरा बता दीजिए मुझे सबको आवाज जा रही है
क्या शिवम को आवाज नहीं जा रही है शायद सो
प्लीज लेट मी नो एवरी बडी आर यू
लिसनिंग वेलकम वेलकम वेलकम
वेलकम सर आपकी बग बाउंट की सारी वीडियोस
देखता हूं प्रैक्टिस भी करता हूं बट सॉरी
मैं लाइव नहीं आ पाता बट थैंक यू फॉर प्र
थैंक यू वेलकम वेलकम वेलकम वेलकम ब्रदर
बहुत बढ़िया देखते
रहो चलिए
तो हां जी तो यहां पर यह पूरी की पूरी एक
रिपोर्ट तैयार हो जाती है आपके लिए पूरी
रिपोर्ट तैयार हो जाती है ठीक है ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस वब रिपोर्ट डिस्क्रिप्शन में क्या
आ जाता है ब्लाइंड क्रॉस स्क्रिप्टिंग वटी
है बन डिस्कवर्ड इन एप्लीकेशन वेर यूजर
इनपुट इ नॉट प्रॉपर्ली सैनिटाइज राइट ओके
यहां पर आप नीचे आ
जाइएगा कॉपी कर लीजिएगा तो कॉपी हो
जाएगा ठीक है यह फॉलोइंग इंफॉर्मेशन वास
कैप्चरड तो यहां पर आपको पूरी इंफॉर्मेशन
जो है वो यहां पे आ जाएगी जो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन है उसके बाद इंपैक्ट यहां पे आ
जाएगा कि द अटैकर कैन यूज दिस व टू स्टल
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन फ्रॉम अदर्स यूजर्स
सच एज लॉगइन क्रेडेंशियल उसके बाद यहां पे
रेडिशन स्टेप्स क्या रेडिशन स्टेप्स होने
चाहिए रिकमेंडेशन क्या है ये सारी चीजें
आपके सामने आ जाएगी इसमें आप अपनी जो
डिटेल्स है ऐड करना है वो ऐड कर दीजिए एंड
दैट्ची नहीं है
राइट
चलिए यह तो हमने टेस्ट पीएचपी पे कर लिया
यहां पे मैंने डिलीट करी रिपोर्ट्स जो थे
एक्सेस फाइ पर चलते
हैं ओके
सॉरी
तो ठीक है अब यहां पे हमने यह किया था
कभी-कभी क्या होती है जब आप एक्सेसेस यहां
पे डालते हो बग्स जब आप यहां पर एक्सस की
ब्लाइंड एक्सेस की पेलोड डालते हो ना तो
कई बार वो पेलोड्स कुछ घंटों में भी
एग्जीक्यूट होते हैं जैसे मान लो तुमने
इनके फॉर्म पे ये कर दिया एक्सेस के पेलो
डाल दिए तुमने सबमिट भी कर दिया अब इस
फॉर्म को कोई एनालाइज करेगा बैक एंड में
तभी ना अब मान लो दो घंटे तक एनालाइज ही
नहीं किया तो 10 घंटे बाद एनालाइज किया तो
एक दिन के बाद एनालाइज किया तो तो जब
एनालाइज करेगा अगर ये वल्नरेबल होगा तो
ओबवियसली इट विल गेट एग्जीक्यूटेड द
एक्सेसेस विल गेट एग्जीक्यूटेड और यहां पे
ये आपका ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस क आएगा सिंपल सा
फंडा है अब मान लो यहां पे तुमने एक पेलोड
का यूज़ किया यहां पे हमने पेलोड पे गए और
हमने एक सिंपल सा पेलोड डाल दिया अभी और
भी पेलोड यूज़ करना है जैसे यहां पे
आईएमजी टैग पेलोड का यूज़ करना है अनदर
बेसिक पेलोड फॉर स्क्रिप्ट टैग्स आर
एक्सप्लीसिटली एक्सप्लीसिटली फिल्टर्ड
मतलब अगर स्क्रिप्ट टैग फिल्टर्ड है तो आप
आईएमजी एसआरसी जो है इसको यूज़ कर सकते
हैं तो हमने यहां पे कॉपी किया कांटेक्ट
पेज पे गए अगेन हमने नेम पे भी डाल दिया
लास्ट नेम में भी डाल दिया कंपनी नेम में
भी डाल दी कंपनी ईमेल यहां हमने कुछ
गड़बड़ यहां पे ईमेल आईडी डाल दी व
ओरिजिनल डालनी पड़ेगी तो हमने क्या किया
फिर से टेंप मेल वाली ईमेल आईडी चूज कर ली
कंट्री यहां पे इंडिया सेलेक्ट कर लिया
फोन नंबर में मैंने 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
डाल दिया ए एनुअल प इतना डाल दिया अगेन
यही सेम पे लोट को यहां से उठाया एंड यहां
डाल दिया एंड यहां पे हमने सबमिट कर दिया
ठीक है सबमिट किया दैट्ची अब अगर कोई भी
फायर होता है इनके फॉर्म से तो हमें यहां
पे यह एक्सस फायर्स के अंदर यहां पे मिल
जाना चाहिए अगर ये वल्नरेबल है अगर ये मिल
जाता है रिपोर्ट बनाइए तैयार कीजिए मस्त
रिपोर्ट कीजिए
दैट्ची चीज हो गई अब मैं क्या बोल रहा हूं
कि आप किन तरीके से और कर सकते हैं
एक्सेसेस फायर का इस ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस का
यूज किस तरीके से और हो सकती है ये भी मैं
आपको दिखाता हूं ठीक है तो मैं अपने बब
शूट को ओपन कर लेता हूं एक बार आई नीड अ
बब शूट फॉर दिस तो लेट मी ओपन द बब शूट ये
रहा सो लेट इट ओपन थैंक यू
थोड़ा सा बढ़ा दो ठीक है मैं थोड़ा सा
साउंड बढ़ाने की कोशिश करता हूं आई थिंक
अब साउंड आपकी बढ़ी हुई आएगी शायद सो आप
देख लीजिए एक
बार धीरे आवाज आ रही है अभी भी धीरे आ रही
है क्या आवाज एक बार देखिए जरा अ लेट मी
नो गाइस इज द ऑडियो स्टिल कमिंग धीरे धीरे
या सही आ रही है
अभी प्लीज
हेलो सर फाइनली कंप्लीटेड माय डे वन टू डे
19 ओहो क्या बात है कांग्रेचुलेशन डे 19
तक कंप्लीट कर लिया आपने क्या बात है बहुत
बढ़िया चलिए तो हमने बॉब शूट को ओपन कर
लिया प्रॉक्सी ऑन ठीक
है बढ़िया
अब साउंड ओके ठीक है ओके मैं अभी अब आपको
और भी तरीके बताऊंगा ये ब्लाइंड एक्सेस का
तो टेंशन आपको नहीं लेनी है अब मान लो मैं
रैपिड प हूं आई एम ऑन रड नेट ठीक है अब
मुझे ब्लाइंड एक्सेस से चेक करने है जैसे
मैं रड नेट पे हूं यहां
पे मैं यहां पे बब शूट ऑन कर देता हूं
इसके
लिए मैं बाकी चीजें ना यहां से हटा देता
हूं फिलहाल के लिए इसको हटा देता हूं एंड
आई एम ऑन बॉब शूट मैं बॉब शूट का यहां पे
प्रॉक्सी इनेबल कर लेता हूं मैं सिंपली
इसको फॉक्सी प्रॉक्सी करके एक प्लगइन आता
है उसको यूज कर रहा हूं बब शूट के
प्रॉक्सी चेंज के लिए ताकि बार-बार सेटिंग
में जाके चेंज ना करना पड़े यहां से बब
शूट किया अब ये बब शूट प स्विच हो चुका है
एंड अब जो है मैं रप n को एक बार रीलोड
मार देता हूं लेट सी इन
टारगेट तो यह रहा रड नेट हमारा टारगेट
सबसे नीचे है आई थिंक यही वाला है
ना जी हां यह रप नेट हमारा आ चुका है ट्स
इट इसको हम ड टू स्कोप कर देते हैं हमने
इसको स्कोप प ऐड
किया फिल्टर में लगा देते हैं ओनली स्कोप
आइटम्स की शो करे वो यहां पर हमारे स्कोप
आइटम्स आ चुके हैं नाउ व्ट आईम गोइंग टू
डू आम गोइंग टू स्पाइडर होस ताकि जितने भी
पैरामीटर हमारे पास आ जाए सारे स्पाइडरिंग
कर लेते हैं सोट ल पैरामीटर्स गट राइट तो
इसको मैं ऐसे कर देता हूं ताकि हमें वैसे
पैरामीटर दिख
जाए पम के अकॉर्डिंग फिल्टर कर लेते हैं
स्टेटस ू ट्स ग्रेट
एंड इस तरीके से आ गई यहां पर अब य पर
सर्च वाली य हमारा पैरामीटर है इसको मैं
क्या करता हूं राइट क्लिक करता हूं एंड
राइट क्लिक करने के बाद सेंड टू रिपीटर कर
देते हैं रिपीटर पे आ जाते हैं रिपीटर पे
हमारा आ चुका है अब हम यहां पे अपने पेलोड
को डाल सकते हैं जो हमारा हंटर का पेलोड
है जैसे हमने यह वाला पेलोड उठाया पेलोड
पे चलते हैं आईएमजीएसआरसी वाली पेलोड उठा
लेते हैं स्क्रिप्ट टैग आर एक्सप्लीसिटली
फिल्टर्ड इसको मैं कॉपी कर लेता हूं एंड
लेट्स पुट ऑन हियर सर्च स्ट्रिंग पे चलते
हैं यहां पे ये तो सर्च स्ट्रिंग है यहां
नहीं करेंगे हम यहां पे नहीं करेंगे ये तो
हम क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग जब
रिफ्लेक्टेड चेक करना हो तब हम यहां पे कर
रहे हैं फिलहाल के लिए अब हम इसमें क्या
करेंगे हम इसमें क्या कर सकते हैं ये
रेफरर हेडर आपको दिख रहा है रेफरर हेडर
राइट ये रेफरल हेडर आप रेफरल हेडर के अंदर
में भी अपनी एक्सेस के पेलोड को घुसा सकते
हो जो आपने यहां पे पेलोड यूज किया है एज
सिंपल एज दैट हमने यहां से कॉपी किया
पेलोड ये वाली कौन सी पेलोड थी ये वाली
पेलोड थी राइट ये वाली पेलोड थी ये हमने
यहां से कॉपी पे किया पेलोड और यहां पने
रेफरल हेडर पे यहां पे इस पेलोड को डाल
दिया अब यहां पे हमरा
यूजर एजेंट पेलोड है यूजर एजेंट हेडर है
सॉरी हम यूजर एजेंट हेडर में भी यह पेलोड
को घुसा देंगे ठीक है बस होस्ट सेडर में
भी घुसा दो अब यहां पे हम इसको गो पे
क्लिक कर देते हैं गो पे क्लिक करते हैं
एंड वी गॉट 200 ओके एंड वी गॉट दिस पेज
दैट्ची यहां पे फायर हुआ है करेंटली कोई
फायर नहीं हुआ कोई बात नहीं इसका मतलब
क्या है कि आप एक्सएसएस की पेलोड को उठाओ
यहां से और जहां जहां घुसा सकते हो भाई
घुसाओ ठीक है जहां एंटर कर सकते हो ना एक
अपने टारगेट के डोमेन को लेके व उसके
एप्लीकेशंस को लेके उसकी फॉर्म को कुछ भी
वहां घुसा दो जैसे मैंने ये तो उठाया
मैंने
देखो यहां आते
हैं यह वाला हमने उठाया था ना हां यह वाला
हमारा पेलो यही वाला रखने देते हैं अब मैं
यहां पे टारगेट प चलता हूं यहां पे और भी
यहां पे बहुत सारे पैरामीटर्स वाले पेज
हमें मिल जाते हैं यहां पे यहां पे
पैरामीटर्स यह आपको यहां पे रेफरल मिल रहा
है यूजर एजेंट मिल रहा है यह एक पैरामीटर
है टाइप इ इक्वल टू ब्लॉग ठीक है हमने
इसको भेजा रिपीटर पे रिपीटर पे आ गए हम
यहां पे टाइप इ इक्वल टू ब्लॉग है यह वाला
जो पैरामीटर है इसके अंदर भी हमने क्या
किया यूजर एजेंट को सिंपल यहां पर रिप्लेस
किया अपने पलट से रेफ जो है उसको हमने
क्या किया रिफ्रेश किया और यहां पर हम
क्या करते हैं एक ओरिजिन नाम का हेडर डाल
देते हैं
ओरिजिन ओरिजिन हेडर डाल देते हैं और यहां
भी हम अपना पेल घुसा देते हैं मतलब जहां
यार गो प क्लिक करो देखो यहां प 403 फॉर
मिडेन आ गया ओ क्या बात है कोई बात नहीं
फॉरन आ गया ना ठीक है तो फॉर्ब डन आ गया
तो हम इस ओरिजिन वाली जो हमारी पेलोड
है ओरिजिन हेडर को हटा के और अब गो पर
क्लिक करते हैं 403 फॉरन आ रहा है ठीक है
देन वी आर रिमूविंग
द
रेफरर चलो रेफरर को हटा देते हैं लेट्स
रिमूव द रेफरर जो पहले था हमारा वही रखते
हैं अब गो प क्लिक करते हैं अब 200 ओके आ
गया हमारा तो हमने यूजर एजेंट में डाला था
ट्स इट हमें यहां पे मिल चुका है अब हम
यहां पर एक्सेस फायर्स को चेक करेंगे लाइक
जब भी हो सके यह फायर हो जाए आज नहीं कल
भी हो सकती है परसों भी हो सकती है दो दिन
बाद भी हो सकती है एक मिनट के बाद भी हो
सकता है दो घंटे के बाद भी हो सकता है
राइट गुड इवनिंग
ओके गट इट तो इस तरीके से आप ये चीज कर
सकते हैं अब मान लो यहां पर मैं और भी चीज
बताता हूं बब शूट का भी यूज करके आप कर
सकते हो आपको जरूरी नहीं है यू शड यू हैव
टू यूज दिस दिस वन बी एक्सस हंटर ओनली आप
ब कोलैबोरेटर का भी यूज करके कर सकते हो
मैं बताऊंगा कैसे करना है बने रहिए साथ
में अब मान लो यहां पे मुझे क्या करना है
हां अब चलो यहां पे पेज प चलते हैं इस पर
आते हैं अब देखो कहां कहां हम घुसा सकते
हैं देखो चलो साइन अप पे लॉग इन पे बढ़िया
गेट स्टार्टेड प कुछ है क्या भाई
क्या मिल रहा है कांटेक्ट फॉर्म आ रहा है
कोई दिक्कत नहीं हटाओ ये वही वा चीज
सपोर्ट सेंटर डेवलपर कम्युनिटी यूज दिस
फॉर्म अरे बाप रे बहुत सारी चीज यहां तो
साइन अप फॉर्म है साइन इन फॉर्म है
डैशबोर्ड यह साइन इन फॉर्म है अब मान लो
साइन इन फॉर्म है यहां पे ठीक है ना अब
साइन इन फॉर्म करना है स्टे यहां पे मैं
फॉरगॉट पासवर्ड प क्लिक करता हूं ईमेल
आईडी यहां प डालना है ओबवियसली सो दिस इज
एन ईमेल आईडी सो ईमेल आईडी यहां पे आप डाल
अभी छोड़ दो ईमेल आईडी साइन अप फॉर्म है
साइन अप फॉर्म प चलते हैं एंड यहां पे
हमने क्या किया फर्स्ट नेम में डाल दिया
मस्ट बी और अच्छा अच्छा यह कैरेक्टर बहुत
बड़ा हो जा रहा है कैरेक्टर यहां पर
फिल्टरिंग हो रही है तो हम छोटे कैरेक्टर
वाले पेलेट को उठा लेते हैं कोई बात नहीं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है कोई भी छोटा एक कैरेक्टर उठा लेते
हैं चलो यह वाला सिंपल हम जो हमारा है यही
वाला उठा लेते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है
यने डाल
दिया लास्ट नेम डाल दिया मस्ट बी 45
कैरेक्टर्स और लेस तो आई थिंक ज्यादा हो
जा रहा है यह हां इनके अकॉर्डिंग यह थोड़ा
सा ज्यादा हो जा रहा है कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है थोड़ा और
भी कोई भी आई एमजीएस आरसी यहां से उठा
लेते हैं
ओके यहां पे कुछ फिल्ट्रेशन लगी है तो आप
कैरेक्टर को छोटा यहां पे कर लेना जैसे
कोई भी पेलोड आप डालना ना यहां पे अपने
कैरेक्टर को छोटा कर लेना कोई भी छोटा
कैरेक्टर का पेलोड डाल देना मान लो यहां प
मैंने यहां पे नितेश ही डाल दिया लास्ट
नेम में मैंने यहां पर सिंह डाल दी ठीक है
कंट्री में मैंने यहां पे इंडिया डाल दिया
ओके यहां पे वाव यार इंडिया है ही नहीं
अरे ये क्या है भाई इंडिया को दिया ही
नहीं भाई इंडिया में है ही नहीं इनका
बिजनेस चलो इंडोनेशिया कर देते हैं कंपनी
वेबसाइट को पेलोड से डाल देते हैं कंपनी
मस्ट कंटेन
एसडीपी पेलो डा इसकी जरूरी नहीं है कंपनी
ईमेल डाल देते हैं हेलो
रेट हेलो डॉट या ऐसे डाल देते कंपनी ईमेल
में यह वाला उठा लेते
हैं पासवर्ड यहां पर डाल देते हैं राइट
कोई सा भी पासवर्ड आप डाल दीजिए यहां
पर ठीक
है पासवर्ड डाल यहां पे आई वांट आई एम
डेवलपर आई वांट टू रिसीव ऑटोमेटिक अपडेट्स
ये वाली चीज कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पे अब
फर्स्ट नेम जो है यहां पर हमें एक सिंपल
सा कोई सा भी हंटर का पेलोड डाल दो भाई
जैसे हमने यही पेलोड यूज किया था ना तो
इसको हम यूज कर लेंगे अगर यहां प कैरेक्टर
लिमिट नहीं हो पा रही है तो बट ठीक है कोई
सा भी द बैकग्राउंड म्यूजिक कूल सर अरे
भाई बैकग्राउंड म्यूजिक बाहर से आ रहा है
कहीं से मेरे साइड से नहीं आ रहा पता नहीं
इससे कहीं कुछ दिक्कत ना हो जाए भाई
कॉपीराइट का इशू बट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
अरे भाई ये नॉर्मल सी है यार नॉर्मल सी
नॉर्मल सी पेलो डाल रहे हो बस और कुछ तो
नहीं कर रहे हो यहां पे और कुछ नहीं यहां
पे बस ब्लाइंड एक्सेस को पॉप अप कराने के
लिए कर रहे हो और क्या कर रहे हो बस सिंपल
सा फंडा है ठीक है और कुछ भी नहीं है तो
ट्स इट हमने यहां पर एक पेलोड उठा लेना है
कोई भी एक पेलोड उठा ले छोटा वाला एंड
आईएमजी का उठा लेते हैं एक
बार
टा
आई थिंक यह वाली पेलोड हमारी काम कर जानी
चाहिए सो लेट्स एंटर दिस पेलोड एंड यहां
पे हमने यहां पे
अ यह वाली हम यहां पे रिप्लेस कर दें अगर
यह यहां पे एक्सेप्ट कर लेता है
तो अ यस तो यह छोटा कर दिया हमने
स्क्रिप्ट एसआरसी यहां पे एंड एडीपीएस कर
दिया हमने आई थिंक
सो यह वाली थी ना हां
जी या सो वी डिड इट एंड उसके बाद यहां पे
हम साइन अप पे क्लिक कर देंगे एंड
एवरीथिंग गोज वेल अगर अगर सब कुछ सही
रहेगा तो यह साइन अप हो जाना चाहिए मेरे
ख्याल से समथिंग वेंट रॉन्ग वी कैन नॉट
क्रिएट योर अकाउंट राइट नाउ कोई बात नहीं
चलो चलता है इसमें अब मान लो यहां पे कोई
एक फीडबैक फॉर्म वगैरह है उसमें भी आप डाल
सकते हैं यहां पे साइन इन फॉर्म है यह
यहां पर साइन अप फॉर्म था साइन अप फॉर्म
था यहां पर ट्स इट एंड यहां नीचे आ जाते
यहां पर इसमें क्या है
यह डेवलपर्स कम्युनिटी यह डेवलपर्स
कम्युनिटी है यह भी बहुत बढ़िया यहां पर
भी एक आपको साइन फॉम मिल जाता है एंड यह
बड़ी अच्छी बात यहां पर हो चुकी है नेम
में यहां पर डाल देते हैं नेम में हम अपना
पेलोड यहां डाल देते हैं कॉपी
टू लेट्स सी इफ इट हैज
सम
ओके फुल नेम यहां पर डाल देना है अपना एंड
पासवर्ड डाल देना
है तो मैं यहां पे पासवर्ड डाल देता हूं
ठीक है यहां पे हमने पासवर्ड डाल दिया हाउ
यू गेट हियर कुछ भी वी आर ऑर्गेनिक सर्च
ईमेल आईडी में मैं यहां पे ईमेल डाल देता
हूं कोई सा भी नर्मल यूजर नेट वी विल ईमेल
यू टू कंफर्म हां ठीक है यह कंफर्म कर रहे
हैं ईमेल करके तो भैया मेरे को यह वाली
ईमेल आईडी चाहिए य ये कंफर्म करो भाई तुम
ताकि मुझे कुछ उसम पता चले यूजर नेम में
मैं यहां पर पूरी पेलो डाल पूरी पेलो डाल
सकता हूं अगर यह यूजर
नेम
लाइक चलो यूजर नेम के लिए मैं कोई और
पेलोड एक बार यह वाली पेलोड कॉपी कर लेता
हूं ओके यूजर नेम इसमें आएगा नहीं सो
लेट्स मिस्टर
परफेक्ट हैकर ठीक है यह वाली यूजरनेम डाल
दी ऑर्गेनिक सर्च एंड यहां प क्रिएट
अकाउंट पर क्लिक कर देंगे राइट तो लेट्स
क्रिएट द अकाउंट लेट्स
क्रिएट
सो हमने अकाउंट क्रिएट कर लिया यहां पे
वेलकम टू द रैपिड डेवलपर कम्युनिटी यहां
पे आ चुका है यहां पे वी आर ऑलमोस्ट डन वी
सेंट एन एक्टिवेशन मेल टू इस प्लीज फॉलो द
इंस्ट्रक्शन अब देखो यहां पे एक एक्टिवेशन
मेल इन्होंने सेंड किया है यह भी कई बार
आपके काम का हो सकता है जैसे ये देखो
रैपिड डेव कम्युनिटी ये एक्टिवेशन मेल
आपके पास आ चुकी है अब इसको भी एनालाइज
करेंगे इस एक्टिवेशन मेल को भी ठीक है
यहां पे क्या इनके डिटेल्स आ रहे हैं क्या
एक्टिवेशन मेल में आ रहा है ये हम चेक आउट
करेंगे तो एक्टिवेशन मेल को ओपन कर लेते
हैं एंड यहां पे आप देखेंगे वेलकम टू
रैपिड डेव कम्युनिटी क्लिक द लिंक टू
कंफर्म एंड एक्टिवेट द न्यू अकाउंट बहुत
बढ़िया कॉपी पेस्ट ठीक है तो मैं यहां पे
क्लिक करता हूं एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग यहां पे ये आ चुका क्लिक हियर टू
एक्टिवेट द अकाउंट जैसे ही मैंने क्लिक
किया क्लिक किया यस योर न्य न्यू अकाउंट
इज कंफर्म्ड यू विल बी रीडायरेक्टेड टू द
होम पेज तो हमारा न्यू अकाउंट क कंफर्म हो
चुका है और हम होम पेज पे आ चुके हैं अब
अगर कहीं मेरा यह फायर हुआ ये एक्सेसेस
बाय चांस ये एक्सेसेस अगर फायर हो हुआ तो
मुझे यहां पे यह फायर वाली जो सीन है
एक्सेसेस फायर्स यहां पे यह आ जाएगा पूरी
डिटेल के साथ एंड अगर यह फायर होके आता है
तो इट मींस देयर इज अ ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस
एंड ये फायर अभी कुछ देर में भी हो सकती
है इंस्टेंट भी हो सकती है एक दिन भी हो
सकता है 2 दिन भी लग सकते हैं सात दिन भी
हो सकता है तो आप सारी जगह डालते जाओ
डालते इसका फायदा यही होता है ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस में ऐसे टूल्स का यूज़ करने का कि
क्या होगा कि ये तो आपका लॉग इन करोगे
आपके अंदर आ जाएगा बर्प कोलैबोरेटर का
यूज़ करोगे उसी टाइम आपको देखना पड़ेगा
एनालाइज करना पड़ेगा ओपन करके रखना पड़ेगा
मैं बताता हूं कैसे करना है बट एक् जब इन
सब टूल्स का यूज करोगे तो आप बेसिकली
एक्सेस फायर्स पे आओगे एंड यहां पे लॉग इन
करके जब भी आपका कोई ऐसा कुछ एग्जीक्यूशन
हुआ रहेगा तो आप यहां पे
आके एंड ये फायर को एनी टाइम चेक कर सकते
हो अब देखो यहां पे एक और इसका अल्टरनेटिव
है
एक्सस एक्सप्रेस हंटर करके एक रिपोजिटरी
है आप आ जाइए एक्सस हंटर एक्सप्रेस आप इस
पर आ जाइएगा यह गेट हप पे आपको मिल जाएगा
एंड बेसिकली ये एक गेट अप पे आपको
रिपोजिटरी है यहां पे सेटअप ये सेटअप इन
फाइ मिनट्स एंड रिक्वायर नो मेंटेनेंस ठीक
है पहले ना एक्सस हंटर नाम की एक टूल थी
एक वेब एप्लीकेशन था जो बहुत ज्यादा
पॉपुलर था बहुत ज्यादा मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं यह
वाली ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस के लिए बहुत ही
ज्यादा पॉपुलर था इसको बाद में डिप्रेशिएट
कर दिया गया बंद कर दी गई ठीक है इस
सर्विस को अब आप इस सर्विस को यूज नहीं कर
सकते बहुत पॉपुलर था बट इसके अल्टरनेट में
मैंने आपको यह बी एक्सेस बताया और साथ में
गिट हप पे ये एक रिपोजिटरी है जिसको कि आप
खुद का एक एक्सेसेस ब्लाइंड एक्सेस हर का
सेट अप कर सकते हैं खुद के लिए एंड आप
उसको यूज कर सकते हैं ठीक है थोड़ा सा
दिमाग लगाएंगे यू विल जस्ट सेट इट अप एंड
यू विल जस्ट स्टार्ट यूजिंग आपको फिर बी
एक्सस यूज करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी ठीक
है खुद का करना चाह रहे अदर वाइज आप ब
एक्सस यूज कर लीजिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
अब मैं यहां पे लोड करता हूं यहां पे अगर
कुछ मिलता है यहां पे तो हमने क्या किया
एक जगह पर गए वहां घुसे एंड वहां पर हमने
एक्सएसएस वाली पेलो डाल दी चलो यह तो एक
हो गया
ये हमने यहां पर पेट बना लिया एंड यहां पर
हमने क्या किया हमने यहां पर अपना अकाउंट
भी एक्टिवेट कर लिया अब यहां पर नीचे आओ
अब यहां पर यह सर्च पैनल है कोई दिक्कत
नहीं न्यू टॉपिक यह भी कुछ दिमाग टकने
वाली बात है न्यू टॉपिक पर आते हैं लेट्स
सी एंड यहां न्यू टॉपिक प हम अपना पेलो
डाल देंगे यह वाली पेलो डाल दी इसमें
थोड़ा सा दूसरा पेलोड यूज कर लेते हैं
राइट यह वाला यूज कर लेते
हैं कहां गया ये तो एक्टिवेशन हो गई है
कांटेक्ट हो चुका है ये रहा तो न्यू टॉपिक
में हम यहां पर अपना एक पेलो डाल देते हैं
राइट डाला ने जनरल टॉपिक रखते हैं ऑप्शनल
टैग्स रखते हैं एंड यहां पे अपनी डिटेल्स
डाल देते हैं एंड यहां पे हम क्रिएट टॉपिक
पे क्लिक कर देते हैं क्रिएट टॉपिक पे
क्लिक करेंगे यहां पे सेविंग आ रहा है एन
एनर ओकर द टाइटल सीम्स अनक्लियर वन वन और
मोर वर्ड्स इज वेरी लॉन्ग तो चलो ये टाइटल
के अंदर ये प्रॉब्लम आ रही है तो मैं क्या
करता हूं टाइटल के अंदर ना मैं दूसरा
पेलोड यूज कर लेता हूं छोटी वाली पेलोड
यूज कर लेता हूं राइट
सो लेट्स यूज दिस क्रिएट टॉपिक एंड लेट्स
सी एंड एनर अकड एक्सेस डिनाइड इन्होंने ये
फि ये फिल्टर कर रहा है एक्सेस डिनाइड
इन्होने कर दिया कोई बात नहीं कोई टेंशन
नहीं है मैंने यहां पे ये चीज कर लीया मैं
टॉपिक डालता हूं अ यहां पे क्रॉस
साइट क्रिएट टॉपिक देखते हैं एक्स डिनाइड
हो जाए यहां पे अब शायद नहीं हो पाएगा ये
तो आप लोग बेसिकली क्या कीजिएगा जब भी आप
देखो यहां पे देखो देखो देखो देखो देखो
यहां पे ये वाली आउटपुट आ गई आपको यह वाली
यह हमने अभी जो डाला था यह हमें कुछ इस
तरह का रिफ्लेक्शन मिला यहां पर देखने को
राइट एंड हमें यहां
पे लेट्स कंट्रोल यू कंट्रोल सोर्स देखते
हैं कंट्रोल एफ एंड डि फ्रक्स सर्च करते
हैं कुछ आया क्या रिफ्लेक्शन में डे
फोनिक्स कोई रिफ्लेक्शन तो नहीं आया बट
यहां जो हमें आउटपुट मिली है यह अच्छी चीज
हो सकती है लेट्स गो टू एक्सेस फायर्स
लेट्स सी इफ य गेट द फायर नहीं हमें कोई
फायर नहीं मिला अभी फिलहाल के लिए
राइट
सॉरी अभी यहां पे कोई भी फायर नहीं मिला
है बट यह फायर मिल भी सकता है यहां पे
हमें फायर मिल सकती है व कोई भी जानता
नहीं है जस्ट कीप अ कीप अ हंटिंग फोकस
करते रहिए यहां पे देख सकते हैं यहां पे
हमें जो आउटपुट मिला था इसमें हमें ये कुछ
रिफ्लेक्शन मिली थी तो जस्ट वी कैन क्लोज
इट राइट वी कैन क्लोज दिस अ डिस्कार्ड कर
देते हैं मतलब मैं बता रहा हूं आपको
कहां-कहां आप एंट्रीज कर सकते हैं
कहां-कहां आप चीजें कर सकते हैं वह सारी
चीजें मैं बता रहा हूं आपको सो लेट्स गो
टू टॉपिक्स इन्होने क्या किया न्यू टॉपिक
प आ ग य
प रिप्ला पर चलते हैं यह रिप्लाई आ रहे
राइट एंड रिप्ला की भी रिप्ला है क्या कुछ
यह रिप्लाई है रिप्लाई है एंड कम्युनिटी
यहां पर शो कम्युनिटी जहां भाई घुसे ना
वहां घुसा देने का है यह क्या
है ओके यहां पर कुछ रिप्लाई करने का सीन
है क्या ऊपर में कुछ होगा ना रिप्लाई करने
का टॉप रिप्लाई वगर जो आ रहे य
पर कमेंट कर चैट बॉक्स यह चैट बॉक्स है य
पर बढ़िया यह चैट बॉक्स य
पर एी सपोर्ट जवाइन कर लेते हैं एपी
सपोर्ट में चलते हैं चैट बॉक्स में य ओके
यहां नीचे आते हैं इफ देर इ सम चैट बॉक्स
थिंग यह रहा
यू कैन नॉट सेंड द मैसेज एट द टाइम
क्योंकि अभी शायद इन्होंने वो किया ब्लॉक
किया है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है इन्होंने पूरा
वो वाला चीज कर दिया चलो यहां पे एपीआई
रेफरेंसेस चलते गेट स्टार्टेड क्लाइंट
पोर्टल ये सारी चीजें सब चीजें छान मारो
भाई जितनी चीजें तुम छान मार सकते हो सब
मारो ये एपीआई डॉक्यूमेंटेशन है बढ़िया
नीचे आ जाओ यह ईमेल आईडी वाली सब्सक्राइब
वाली चीज है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं यहां पे
यह कांटेक्ट अस है गट फीडबैक यह रहा
फीडबैक फॉर्म में मिल गया भाई ओहो फीडबैक
लेट अस
नो फीडबैक फॉर्म पर चलते
हैं ये तो ग डॉक्स प फीडबैक ले रहे हैं
कोई काम का नहीं हमारे
हटाओ तो नीचे आ जाते हैं यहां पे डेवलपर
कम्युनिटी कांटेक्ट अस प्राइवेसी
पॉलिसी यहां कुछ भी नहीं
है क्लाइंट पोर्टल है यहां पे व्हाट इज द
क्लाइंट पोर्टल लॉग इन कुछ अलग है क्या
लॉगिन का यहां पे सीन का डैशबोर्ड वाला ही
लॉगइन है तो हमारे काम का नहीं
है हमारे काम का नहीं है इसको मैं यहां पे
थोड़ा सा कम कर देता
हूं चलो एक तो हमें ये चीज मिली थी बहुत
बढ़िया नाउ हम
अपने रप नेट पे चलते हैं वापस से हम अपने
टारगेट पे सॉरी और हां ये चेक करते रहना
भाई कि कहीं कोई फायर तो नहीं आया हां
इसमें एक और चीज है आप सेटिंग्स में
जाएंगे यहां पे तो सेटिंग्स में जाएंगे तो
आप नोटिफिकेशन सेटिंग्स में जाएंगे सॉरी
कनेक्टेड सर्विस में तो आप अपने ईमेल
नोटिफिकेशन इनेबल कर सकते हैं जैसे कोई
फायर होता है कोई नोटिफिकेशन आती है ईमेल
पे आपकी आ जाएगी उसके अलावा आप डिस्कार्ड
एंड स्लैक पे भी अपनी नोटिफिकेशंस मंगा
सकते हैं ठीक है डिस्कार्ड वाले वेब य
वेबक वेब हुक यूआरएल डाल दीजिएगा
नोटिफिकेशन इनेबल कर दीजिएगा डिस्कॉर्डेंट
फिकेशन मिलने शुरू हो जाएगी राइट
दैट्ची क्या कर सकते हैं इसमें एक और चीज
आप क्या कर सकते हैं जैसे आप किसी को
लेट्स सपोज ना कोई मेल कर
रहे कोई भी किसी भी तरह का ईमेल कर रहे
मान लो वैसे करके किसी भी चीज के तो आप
उसमें पर्टिकुलर में पर्टिकुलर ईमेल के
अंदर में भी आप एक्सेस पेलोड को डाल के
भेज सकते हैं मे बी इट कैन गेट
एग्जीक्यूटेड और देन व आपका एक्सेप्ट हो
जाएगा ठीक
है तो हमें अभी यहां पर तो और कुछ नहीं
मिल रहा
ना
कंट्री स्पेसिफिक भी है यहां
पर फ्रांसिया यह क्या है फ्रांस वाली जो
वेबसाइट है इनका यह वाला है नीचे आते हैं
नीचे आते
हैं व्यू पर क्लिक करते हैं नीचे आते हैं
नीचे
आते एनीथिंग यर कांटेक्ट
सेल्स यहां पर कोई ऐसा
पेज रिपोर्ट अ
बग बग रिपोर्टिंग आ गई सिक्योरिटी
प्लांसेस पॉलिसी एंड गाइडलाइंस प्रोविडेंट
गेट स्टार्टेड
ओके ब्लॉग एंड रिसोर्सेस सपोर्ट
सेंटर बिकम अ पार्टनर ये अच्छी बात
है अ रैबिट प्राइसिंग करियर्स पे चलते हैं
इवेंट्स पे चलते हैं अ यहां पे - कमर्स
प्लगइन विक्स प्लगइन ये तो पेमेंट्स
प्लगइन जो सपोर्ट करते हैं उसका है फिटेक
वेंचर ग बिकम अ पार्टनर ठीक है ये सारी
चीजें हमने देख ली ठीक है अब एक काम करते
हैं यहां आते हैं रिसोर्सेस पे
इफ वी गेट समथिंग हियर नथिंग मच कांटेक्ट
प य तो कांटेक्ट हमने देख ही लिया था
एक्सप्लोर कर लिया था ऑलरेडी सो
नथिंग कंप्लायंस यहां पर कुछ और है यहां
पर कुछ भी नहीं है रैपिड सिक्योरिटी तो
साइबर ठीक
है ओके कुछ भी नहीं य
पर ठीक है प्र बिजनेस पॉलि सी ये है
ओके एक्सप्लोर आवर डॉक्स इसम चलते हैं
कांटेक्ट र्स तो हमने देखा ही
था रिपोर्ट बग ऑन रैपिड नेट इस पर क्लिक
करते हैं लेट्स सी इनका खुद का कुछ है
क्या विजिट आ बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम पेज
अच्छा यह शायद बक क्राउड से है तो इसलिए
इन्होंने लिंक दे दिया है कि वहां सबमिट
कर सकते हैं और कुछ यहां पे हमें नहीं मिल
रहा राइट सो वी विल जस्ट इग्नोर इट मतलब
अब
देखो हां जी तो कहां-कहां पे आप डाल सकते
हैं यह मैंने आपको बताया था तो यह थोड़ा
जरूरी है इन द इन कमेंट बॉक्स के अंदर डाल
सकते हैं साइन अप फॉर्म्स के अंदर डाल
सकते हैं कांटेक्ट फॉर्म्स के अंदर डाल
सकते हैं फीडबैक फॉर्म्स के अंदर डाल सकते
हैं रेफरर हेडर के अंदर डाल सकते हैं
होस्ट हेडर के अंदर डाल सकते हैं ओरिजिन
के अंदर डाल सकते हैं एंड यूजर एजेंट के
अंदर भी आप डाल सकते हैं एंड किसी भी
पैरामीटर्स प ये आप चीज ध्यान रखिएगा किसी
भी पैरामीटर किसी भी अ लाइक रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर जो है उसके बहुत सारे पैरामीटर्स पे
आप डाल सकते हैं अपने पेलोड को एंड उसको
भेज दीजिए मतलब सब सारे एक्सेसेस ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस का यहां पे सीन ये है कि जहां-जहां
डाल सकते हो पेलोड ब्लाइंड एक्सेस की
डालते जाओ भूलते जाओ डालते जाओ भूलते जाओ
और उसको मॉनिटर करो कि भैया कहां-कहां कुछ
फायर हुआ है कि नहीं आगे एक एक बार चेक
करते रहो ये फायर वाली बॉक्स जब यहां पे
तुम्हें दिखेगी फायर वाली तो तुम्हें बड़ा
मजा आएगा जैसे टेस्ट पीएचपी में हमें दिखा
था फायर वाला तो बहुत मजा आया था तो वैसे
ही यहां पे फायर वाला देखोगे अगर कुछ आ
रहा है यहां पे फायर हो रहा है तो आपको
बहुत मजा आएगा राइट तो इस तरी आप चीज कर
सकते
हैं ठीक है यहां पर जॉइन एक ये देख लेते
हैं लेट्स क्लोज ल दिस थिंग्स डों नीड
थ सॉरी यह एक मोमेंट आया जॉइन द मोमेंट
जॉइन द मोमेंट नेट यहां पर कुछ जॉइन द
मोमेंट द मोमेंट प्रीवियसली इवेंट्स कुछ
इस तरीके का आ रहा
है कुछ आ रहा है ये
गेट द डांसिंग शूज बिकॉज दे ठीक है यहां
पर कुछ
आया वी गेट नथिंग राइट कुछ भी फिलहाल नहीं
मिला यहां पर यहां पर मिल जाते हैं को डट
आईस है यहां पर डट एच के है को ड आस प हम
चल देते हैं यह हमारा टारगेट फिलहाल य
टारगेट
रखते इ इट ओपनिंग इट्स नॉट ओपनिंग
यर . कॉ लेट्स ओपन इट लेट्स ओपन इट
n.com कुछ भी नहीं य पर आ रहा है ऐसा
क्यों हो रहा है मैं डिसेबल कर देता हूं
एक बार बब शूट को वापस से ओपन कर लेता
हूं ट कर्स कॉ को ओपन कर लेते हैं लेट्स
सी जी हां तो यह सेम उसी का ही है यह
लॉगइन पैनल
है और रप ओजी को हम यहां पर ओपन कर लेते
हैं इफ इट इज ओपनिंग इट इज ओपनिंग इट्स
नॉट एक्सेसिबल id.com को एक बार ओपन कर
लेते हैं लेट्स सी व्ट इज हैपनिंग
हियर सेम चीज है कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हम
यहां पर कोई और टारगेट को भी चूज आउट कर
सकते
हैं लेट्स चूज सम अदर टारगेट प्रोग्राम्स
प चलते
हैं लेट्स गो टू द
प्रोग्राम हां इसके टूल्स के लिए अगर मैं
बात करूं यहां पे तो टूल्स का मैंने
ऑलरेडी बता दिया ऑनलाइन टूल बी एक्सस हंटर
यूज कर लीजिए ठीक है बर्ब कोलबेट को यूज
कर सकते हैं यहां
पे
एक्सप्रेस हंटर गेट हब से आप खुद का बना
सकते हैं यह तीन चीजें आप कर सकते हैं
फिलहाल के लिए अब मैं ब कोलबेट का भी
थोड़ा सा आपको आईडिया देता हूं बब
कोलैबोरेटर के लिए आप कैसे यूज कर सकते
हैं किस तरीके से आप उसको ट्राई आउट कर
सकते हैं ठीक है जैसे मान लो मैं यहां पर
टेस्ट पीएचपी प आ जाता हूं यहां पे लेट्स
कम टू द टेस्ट पीएचपी एंड लेट्स ओपन
इट प्रोफाइल प चलता हूं मैं यहां पे यहां
पे प्रोफाइल प आके यहां पे यह वाली जो
चीजें है वो आ चुकी है अब यहां प मुझे
पेलोड अपना डालना है ठीक है इस पे पेलोड
का यूज करना है बप कोलैबोरेटर का तो इसके
लिए आपको बब शूट ओपन कर लेना है कुछ इस
तरीके से आपका बब शूट ओपन हो जाएगा राइट
अब मान लो मुझे क्या करना है बल्ब
कोलैबोरेटर को यहां पे इंसर्ट करना है
बल्ब कोलैबोरेटर को एज अ हमारे पेलोड के
लिए यूज करना है राइट तो हम कोई भी
आईएमजीएसआरसी पेरोड हम यूज कर सकते हैं
एंड वहां पे बब कोलबो मेटर के जो यूआरएल
है उसको पुट डाउन कर सकते हैं राइट जैसे
मान लो मैं बीएक्स में गया यहां पे
पेलोड्स पे चलता हूं मैं यहां पे एंड यहां
पे मैं यहां पे इसको कॉपी कर लेता हूं
कॉपी मैंने किया अब यहां पे आई एम गोइंग
टू डू व्हाट आई एम गोइंग यहां पे एंड इस
पेलोड के जगह पे यह जो पेलोड है
मेरा इस पेलोड में मैं य बब कोलबेट को ओपन
करूंगा कैसे ओपन करूंगा बब पर जाना है
आपको बब कोलैबोरेटर क्लाइंट ये आपको
दिखेगा राइट ठीक है मैं
जो सर आपको देखकर दूसरे यूट्यूब ने बग
बाउंट की सीरीज जवाइन
करी चलो ब बहुत बढ़िया अच्छी बात है अच्छी
बात है यह तो अच्छी बात है ना कोई आपसे
इंस्पायर हो रहा है तो है ना अगर आपसे कोई
इंस्पायर हो रहा है तो दिस इज अ गुड थिंग
और बैड थिंग ये बताइए आप लोग लेट्स सपोज
लेट्स सपोज अगर मुझसे कोई इंस्पायर हो रहा
है या आपसे कोई इंस्पायर हो रहा है तो यह
अच्छी चीज है या बुरी चीज है कोई इंस्पायर
होके बग बाउंट की क्लासेस दे रहा है तो
बताइए क्योंकि लोग देख रहे हैं ट्रैक्शन
को देख रहे हैं और कुछ नहीं है इसलिए वो
शुरू कर दे रहे हैं और लोग क्या है ना लोग
सोच रहे हैं कि अरे यार बग बांटी की इसने
सीरीज स्टार्ट की है इतना अच्छे इतने
अच्छे मतलब इसके पास ऑडियंस आ चुकी है लोग
इतना पसंद कर रहे देख रहे हैं तो हम भी
स्टार्ट कर देते हैं तो वो वो चीज देख के
स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं तो बग बाउंट कम्युनिटी
के लिए अच्छी है यूजर्स के लिए अच्छी है
हंटर्स के लिए अच्छी है जो सीखना चाहते
हैं स्टूडेंट्स उनके लिए अच्छा है बट मैं
यहां पर पैशन के कारण सिखा रहा हूं मेरे
को अंदर से आता है कि सिखाना है पैशन है
मजा आता है मुझे सिखाने में इसलिए सिखा
रहा हूं बाकी लोगों का मुझे कुछ आईडिया
नहीं है तो आप लोगों के लिए तो बेनिफिशियल
है ना भाई अगर मान लो जिओ आया j ने आके
पूरी इंटरनेट की हिस्ट्री में एक
रिवोल्यूशन ला दी जहां आपको 50 का एक जीबी
डाटा मिलता था अब तो भाई 250 में
अनलिमिटेड मिल रहे हैं डाटा तो ओबवियसली
दे आर प्रेज वर्दी उन्होंने आखिर लाया ना
उस जगह प उन लोगों को बाकी ऑपरेटर्स को तो
भाई मैं अगर फ्री में आपको डिलीवर कर रहा
हूं बाकी लोग भी कर रहे हैं इट्स गुड फॉर
यू आपके लिए वो अच्छा है समझिए इस चीज
को बहुत बढ़िया यहां पे बर्ब कोलैबोरेटर
क्लाइंट इसको आपको ओपन कर लेना है ओपन
करेंगे तो यहां पे आपको कॉपी टू क्लिप
बोर्ड करना है यहां पे आपको एक यूआरएल मिल
जाता है अब ये कोलैबोरेटर क्या होता है
बर्ब कोलैबोरेटर मैं आपको समझा देता हूं
ये है क्या देखिए क्लिक कॉपी टू क्लिप
बोर्ड टू जनरेट बर्ब कोलबेट पेलोड्स दैट
यू कैन यूज इन योर ओन टेस्टिंग एनी
इंटरेक्शन दैट रिजल्ट फ्रॉम यूजिंग द
पेलोड्स विल अपीयर बिलो ठीक
है समझ में आ गया ये चीज ये एक ऐसा सर्वर
है है बर्ब कोलैबोरेटर क्लाइंट क्या है ना
एक तरह का सर्वर मान लो एक तरह का क्लाइंट
सर्वर मान लो जो भी मान लो एक तरह का आप
खुद का सर्वर जो है उसपे भी आप यह चीज
करके आप सर्वर पे यूआरएल को बेसिकली यूज
कर सकते हो एंड उसके लॉग्स को अ अ लाइक
लॉग्स को आप मॉनिटर करके एंड वहां पे आप
अपने जो भी रिस्पांसस आ रहे हैं इंटरेक्शन
आ र उसको देख सकते हो अब यहां पे आप जैसे
ही कॉपी टू क्लिप पोर्ड करोगे आपको एक
यूआरएल मिल जाएगा
देखो यह वाला यह यूआरएल मिल गया यह देखो
एक समथिंग यह आईडी मिल गई आपको ये वाली
आईडी मिल गई और एक ये आपका डोमेन बब कबोट
नेट आपको मिल गया ठीक है अब इसको आपको यूज
करना है अपने पेलोड के अंदर में तो मैं
क्या करूंगा इसको यूज कर कंट्रोल सी कर
लूंगा यहां पे और बी एक्सस इन वाली जो
मेरी यहां पे यह जो मेरा यूआरएल है मैं
यहां पे यह वाली यूज कर लूंगा ठीक है
सिंपल और मेरा जो पेलोड है ये पेलोड यही
रहा पेलोड सिंपल अब मैं इसको यहां पे कॉपी
कर लूंगा पेलोड को अब मैं यहां पे क्या
करूंगा इस पेलोड को यहां पे पेस्ट करूंगा
जहां पे मुझे लगता है एक्सेसेस हो सकता है
वहां मैं पेस्ट करूंगा यहां पे एड्रेस में
भी पेस्ट कर देता हूं फोन नंबर में कुछ भी
डाल देता हूं ईमेल आईडी कुछ भी एंड यहां
पे मैं यहां पे अपडेट पे क्लिक कर दूंगा
जैसे ही मैं अपडेट पे क्लिक करूंगा यहां
पे माय स्कल इंजेक्शन कुछ एरर आ रही है
ठीक है मैं इसको क्या कर देता हूं
[संगीत]
अ ठीक है चलो कोई बात नहीं यहां पे मैंने
ये किया एंड
दैट्ची टाइम में करना है है तो आप पॉल नाउ
पे क्लिक कीजिए अगर कोई इंटरेक्शन होती है
तो आपको यहां पे दिखने को आ जाएगी जैसे
मैंने पॉल नाउ किया अगर कोई इंटरेक्शन
होती है अभी कुछ नहीं हो रहा अभी कुछ हम
नहीं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अब यहां पे पलन
पे क्लिक करेंगे अभी भी कुछ नहीं हुआ
क्योंकि हमारे हमारा पलट कौन सा यूज किया
था हमने यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट एसआरसी यूज की
थी हमने यहां पे सिंपल सा ये पेलोड यूज़
किया था चलो अब एक और पेलोड यूज कर लेते
हैं अ
[संगीत]
लाइक यहां पे मैं ये वाली पेलोड यूज कर
लेता हूं ब्लाइंड एक्सेस की अब ये पेलोड
को मैं यहां पे एंटर कर देता हूं एंड
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग मैंने क्या
किया
नेम में ये डाला पेलोड एड्रेस में भी ये
पेलोड डाल दिया यहां पे अपडेट प क्लिक कर
दिया ठीक है अपडेट प क्लिक कर दिया एंड
यहां पे मैं बप कोलबेट पे आ गया कोलबो र
क्लाइंट पे अगर कोई इंटरेक्शन होती है मैं
यहां पे पल पॉल नाउ पे क्लिक करूंगा पॉल
नाउ पे यहां पे क्लिक करूंगा दो तीन बार
क्लिक करूंगा लेट्स सी अगर कोई इंटरेक्शन
होती है तो हम उस इंटरेक्शन को यहां प
कैप्चर कर सकते हैं अच्छा ये कॉपी टू
क्लिपबोर्ड मैंने शायद पेलोड में ना ये
अभी वाली नहीं डाली है तो मैं यहां पर अभी
वाली जो हमारी पेलोड है वो डाल देता हूं
ठीक है
ये वाली एंड इसको क्लोज कर देते हैं
दैट्ची इस रिजल्ट में आपको एसटीटीपी का
यहां पे रिजल्ट देखने को मिल रहा है जब आप
इस पे जाएंगे तो आपको यहां पे दिख रहा
होगा द रिक्वेस्ट वाज रिसीवड फ्रॉम आईपी
एड्रेस दिस आईपी एड्रेस एंड ये आईपी
एड्रेस कौन सा है भैया आपके टेस्ट पीएचपी
वाली आईपी एड्रेस है ठीक है ये आईपी
एड्रेस ओके तो वी गॉट द आईपी एड्रेस हियर
कि कहां से मुझे मिला है भैया ये तो मुझे
यहां से मिला है रिक्वेस्ट टू कोलैबोरेटर
में आप जाएंगे तो ये रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो
आपको दिख जाएगी रिक्वेस्ट और इसकी हेडर्स
दिख जाएगी रिस्पांस फ्रॉम कोलैबोरेटर में
जाइएगा तो ये आपको रिस्पांस जो है बॉडी वो
आपको दिख जाएगी ठीक है एज सिंपल एज दैट तो
हमें यानी कि इस आईपी से एक इंटरेक्शन
मिला है और यहां हमने अपने पेलोड को डाला
हुआ था तो हम अब क्या कर सकते हैं
एक्सेसेस के लिए रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं यानी
कि वो पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट हुआ है तभी वो
इंटरेक्शन हुआ है किसी तरह का एंड देन अ
वी आर कंफर्म बस तो बप कोलबो मेटर का यूज़
आप इस तरीके से एक छोटा सा आप ये सर्वर
मान लीजिए रिसीविंग सर्वर लिसनिंग सर्वर
मान लीजिए जहां पे आप जो भी इसका यूआई ये
ये यूआरएल यहां से कॉपी कर सकते हैं कॉपी
टू क्लिपबोर्ड से एंड उसके बाद अपने
पेलोड्स के अंदर इंसर्ट कीजिए और
जहां-जहां डालना है डाल दीजिए बट ये वही
बात है कि जब तक बब कोलैबोरेटर को ओपन
करके रखेंगे ओबवियसली क्योंकि ये चेंज हो
जाएगा बार-बार जब आप इसको दोबारा ओपन
करेंगे तो यहां पे जब आप कॉपी करेंगे ना
कॉपी टू क्लिपबोर्ड तो आपका यूआरएल चेंज
हो जाएगा बार-बार चेंज हो जाएगा जैसे अभी
आपका ये बर्ब कोलैबोरेटर यूआरएल क्या था
सॉरी यह वाला आपका यूआरएल था अब मैं अगर
कोलैबोरेटर पे आता हूं यहां पे अब मैं
यहां पे कॉपी टू क्लिप बोर्ड करूंगा ना तो
ये अब चेंज हो गया रहेगा ये देखिए ये चेंज
हो गया ये आईडी आपकी चेंज होती जाएगी अब
मैं वापस से यहां पे
जाऊंगा सॉरी एंड यहां पे क्लिप कॉपी
करूंगा यहां पे य एंटर करूंगा तो ये अगेन
यहां पे चेंज हो जाएगा इसलिए यह बारबार
चेंज होता है इसलिए आप इस तरह के टूल्स का
बी एक्सेस हंटर जैसे टूल का यूज कर सकते
हैं एक्सेस फायर्स को आप कभी भी चेक आउट
कर सकते हैं कहीं कोई फायरिंग हुआ कहीं
कुछ हुआ तो आपके पास वो मिल जाएगा अब देखो
सबसे बड़ी बात एक्सेस तो मिल गया यू
गॉट कहां पे थे हम इस वाले में थे ना हां
ये रहा
अब य पर आते यू गट एक्सेसेस
नाउ
ट नाउ
व्ट तो वी कैन ट्राई वी कैन ट्राई
टू वी कैन ट्राई टू चेन एक्सेसेस
टू अकाउंट
टेकओवर और इवन
एसएसआरएफ
और इवन अदर हाई सीवियरिंग
वल्नरेबल
ठीक है अब यहां पे हम एसएसआरएफ की बात तो
करेंगे नहीं क्योंकि हमने यह चीज अभी करी
नहीं है जब करेंगे तो भी उस टाइम में
करेंगे हम यहां बात कर रहे हैं अब हम जब
एक्सएसएस हमें मिल ही चुका तो या तो आप
उसको रिपोर्ट कर दो एक्सेसेस को एज सिंपल
एज दैट या तो आप उस एक्सेसेस
को किसी हायर सीवियरिंग वनबिल में चेन कर
दो यह सिर्फ एक्सेसेस के लिए नहीं है यह
किसी भी बग बाउंट में कि किसी भी बग के
लिए अगर आपको कोई लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट मिलता
है कोई लोअर सवेरिन है कोई लेस सवेरिन है
तो आप आप रिपोर्ट तो कर लो ठीक है बट
रिपोर्ट करने से पहले थोड़ा सोचो एंड
थोड़ा एफर्ट डालो एक मिनट ऐड आ चुकी है
मैं इसको बंद कर देता हूं थोड़ा एफर्ट
डालो एंड ट्राई करो उसको हाई सीविरियस
करो अगर वो कर सकते हो चेन अप तो अच्छी
बात है नहीं कर सकते छोड़ दो वही जो है
उसी को कर लो य पर उसी को रिपोर्ट बस
सिंपल सा फंडा है अब यहां पर जैसे मेरे
पास मेरे को यह प्रोफाइल में को एक्सेस
मिला मेरे को प्रोफाइल में क्या मिला मुझे
यहां पर एक्सेस मिल गया लेट सपोज य मुझे
कुकीज वैल्यू मिल जाएगी अब मैं इस कुकीज
वैल्यू को यहां पर मुझे कुकीज वैल्यू मिल
जाएगी कैसे कैसे मिलेगा जैसे कैसे कर सकते
हैं य मैंने क्या किया
टेस्ट
टेस्ट मैं यहां लॉगइन किया अब मैं यहां पे
एक अ एक्सेस पलो डालता हूं अ लाइक
स्क्रिप्ट अलर्ट स्क्रिप्ट एंड यहां पे
अलर्ट में क्या कर देता हूं मैं
डॉक्यू मेंट डॉट
कुकी ये मैंने यहां पे एक पेलो डाल दिया
डॉक्यूमेंट डॉ कुकी ये डाल दिया हमने एंड
अलट कर दिया यहां पे यहां पे भी हमने यह
डाला एंड यहां पे हमने अपडेट कर दिया अब
यहां पर जैसे ही मैंने अपडेट किया यहां पर
मुझे क्या मिला एक एक कुकी वैल्यू मिल
चुकी
है समझ में आ गया सिंपल सा कुकी वैल्यू
मिल गया लॉगिन इ इक्वल टू यह वाली कुकी
वैल्यू मुझे मिल गई यह तो मेरा एक्सएसएस
हो गया पॉप अप किया एक्सस हो गया कुकी
वैल्यू मिल गई अब मान लो कि मैं क्रम प आ
जाता हूं एंड यहां पर मैं टेस्ट पीएचपी
मैंने यहां पर लॉग आउट कर देता हूं मैं
टेस्ट पीएचपी को मैंने लॉग आउट कर दिया
मैं यहां पर
सॉरी मैं यहां पर होम प क्लिक कर देता
एंड इसको रीलोड कर देता हूं अब य मेरा
लॉगिन नहीं है मैं साइन अप पर जाऊंगा सॉरी
साइन जाऊंगा तो मुझसे लगिन मांगेगा इट
आस्किंग फॉर लगन ए सिंपल मैंने क्या किया
था मैंने यहां से एक्सस के थ्रू यह कुकी
निकाली सोचो एक्सस को अकाउंट टेकओवर में
कैसे आप कन्वर्ट कर सकते हो कैसे आप जा
सकते हो लेके यह मैं ट्राई कर रहा हूं
आपको बताने की अब मुझे यह कुकी वैल्यू मिल
गई मैंने य कोई कुकी वैल्यू जो
है यहां
पर ओके कर
ठीक है अब मैं यहां पर मान लो इस वाले पेज
पर आ जाता हूं मैं यहां पर बब शूट को
इनेबल कर देता हूं बब शूट को य इनेबल करता
हूं कम में मैं यहां पर चलता हूं इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं यस यहां पर चलता हूं
मैं यहां पर इंटरसेप्ट को मैं यहां पर ऑन
कर देता हूं एंड यहां पर आई एम जस्ट
ट्राइट लॉग
इन मैं यहां पे लाइक ए बी सी एंड एक्स वाई
जड मैं यहां पर य लॉगइन करता हूं
इंटरसेप्ट कर रहा हूं मैं इसको फॉरवर्ड कर
फॉरवर्ड करता हूं टेस्ट पीएचपी व web.com
यहां पर आ चुका है यहां पे अब यहां पर आप
देख सकते हैं यूजर नेम एंड पासवर्ड यहां
पर हमारे पास आ चुकी है ठीक है यह यूजर
नेम एंड यह पासवर्ड आ चुका ठीक है अब मैं
इसको राइट क्लिक करता हूं डू इंटरसेप्ट
रिस्पांस फ्रॉम दिस रिक्वेस्ट फॉरवर्ड
करता हूं यहां पे यहां पे फॉरवर्ड जब
करेंगे यहां पे तो यहां पर आपको एक सिंपल
सा यह रिक्वेस्ट ही है फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
यह रिक्वेस्ट है फॉरवर्ड करते हैं यह आपका
यहां पर रिस्पांस आ रहा
है ठीक है यह रिस्पांस आ अब ये रिस्पांस
यहां पर हमें क्या मिली थी कुकी वैल्यू
मिली थी क्या कुकी थी भैया यहां पे लॉगिन
इ इक्वल टू टेस्ट टेस्ट टेस्ट ये कुकी
वैल्यू मिल गई थी अब यहां पे मान लो यह
रिस्पांस है यह रिस्पांस में हम आ रहा है
यू मस्ट लॉग इन राइट यू मस्ट लॉग इन अब आप
उस कुकीज वैल्यू को इंसर्ट कर सकते हैं
एंड ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं इफ यू कैन लॉग
इन इफ यू कैन लॉग इन सिंपल एज सिंपल एट तो
मान लो सर्वर से ही मैं कुकी वैल्यू को
यहां पे सेट करता हूं य पे सेट
कुकी एंड यहां पे मैं अगर फॉरवर्ड कर देता
हूं एंड अगर यह बेसिकली काम करता है तो
यहां पर आपका सिंपल लॉगिन हो जाना चाहिए
तो यहां पे सिंपल मैं क्या कर देता हूं
सेट कुकीज सेट
कुकीज लेट्स
ओपन इंटरसेप्ट में यहां पे सेट कुकी कर
देते हैं एक बार मैं यहां पे फिर से कुछ
भी डाल देता हूं यहां कुछ भी डाल देता हूं
मैं यहां पर एक बार इंटरसेप्ट कर लेता हूं
इंटरसेप्ट ऑन कर लेता हूं लेट्स प्रेस द
लॉगइन बटन लेट्स कैप्चर इट ये हमने यहां
पे कैप्चर कर लिया यहां पे राइट यहां पे
हम राइट क्लिक करते हैं इंटरसेप्ट टू
रिस्पांस इंटरसेप्ट करते हैं फॉरवर्ड कर
देते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां पर यहां पे
फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं रिस्पांस आ रहा है
यहां पे सेट
कुकी यहां पे हमने कुकी वैल्यू यहां
पे यह कुकी वैल्यू यहां पे हमने डाल दिया
सेट कुकी हमने डाला यहां पे फॉरवर्ड किया
यहां प इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर दिया
एंड लेट्स क्लिक ऑन
हियर अच्छा एक काम करते हैं यहां पे एक
काम करते हैं यहां
पे चलते हैं यहां पे एंड यहां पे टेस्ट
एंड टेस्ट यह किया हमने यहां इंटरसेप्ट को
ऑन किया यहां लॉग इन कर लेते हैं एक चीज
जस्ट लेट मी सी फॉरवर्ड करते यहां पे एंड
दिस वन इज हियर ठीक है दिस वन इज
हियर ओके हमने यहां पे इसको नहीं
किया सॉरी मैं लॉग आउट कर देता हूं यहां
पे यहां प प्रोफाइल प चलते हैं ठीक है
यहां पर हमने टेस्ट किया टेस्ट किया एंड
लेट्स इंटरसेप्ट इज ऑन लेट्स क्लिक द
लॉगिन बटन लेट्स गो हियर लेट्स ये
रिक्वेस्ट आ गई राइट क्लिक किया इंटरसेप्ट
करेंगे इसके रिस्पांस को यहां फॉरवर्ड
करेंगे फॉरवर्ड करेंगे फॉरवर्ड करेंगे ये
रिस्पांस आपकी आ गई यहां पे ये ये आपकी
रिस्पांस आ गई एंड यहां पे आपका सेट कुकी
जो है ये वाला पैरामीटर ये पैरामीटर ये
आपके सर्वर से पैरामीटर आता है राइट ये
आपका पैरामीटर कहां से आता है सर्वर से
आपका पैरामीटर आता है रिस्पांस में आपका
आता है और ये रिस्पांस आपको अपना खुद का
जो कुकी वैल्यू मुझे यहां से मिली है ये
मुझे कुकी वैल्यू मिल गई सेट कुकी
पैरामीटर लगा सकते हैं अब जैसे मैं यहां
पे गया सॉरी यहां पर मैं आया मैं यहां पे
लॉग आउट कर देता हूं यहां पे अगेन आई एम
डूइंग लॉग आउट ठीक है यहां पर मैं इसको
रीलोड कर देता हूं टेस्ट पीएचपी को सॉरी
यहां प ऐड आ गई
है ओके ठीक है अब मैं यहां प साइन अप पे
जाता हूं यहां पर मैं कुछ भी डालता हूं
मैं ए बी सी एक्स वाई जड एंड लेट्स क्लिक
द लॉगइन बिफोर दैट इंटरसेप्ट ऑन लॉगइन पर
क्लिक करता हूं ठीक है यहां पर हम आ चुके
हैं दिस इज द रिक्वेस्ट ट इ
गोइंग फॉरवर्ड टेस्ट पीएचपी यह रिक्वेस्ट
आ गई यहां पे अब यहां प ना कुकीज अब वो तो
सेट कुकीज आपके बना के आ रहा है सेट कुकी
आपका बना के जा रहा है जो सर्वर है वो सेट
कुकी बना के दे रहा है ठीक है तो हम यहां
पर क्या कर देते हैं फॉरवर्ड यहां पर कर
देते हैं इसको राइट क्लिक करते हैं
इंटरसेप्ट करते हैं रिस्पांस को यहां पर
फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं अभी भी यह अभी शायद
नहीं हुआ ठीक है फॉरवर्ड यहां से फॉरवर्ड
करते हैं आई थिंक इट्स लोडिंग स्टल
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं ये रिस्पांस आया ठीक है
कि यहां से भैया आप देखिए अब इसमें क्या
कर देते
हैं सेट कुकी हमने कर दिया एंड यहां पे
इसको फॉरवर्ड करके इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर
देते हैं जैसे हमने फॉरवर्ड किया आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे कि हम यहां पे लॉग इन हो
चुके हैं वी लगड इन ठीक है समझ में आ
गया हां हां कुकी वैल्यू सर्वर सेंड करेगा
आपका सेट कोकी वैल्यू देखा आपने हमने जैसे
ही यहां पे कुकीज निकाली यहां पे हमने
सर्वर के रे ंस हेडर में चेंज किया सेट
कुकी हेडर लगाया क्योंकि कुकी जो हेडर है
वो आपका क्लाइंट भेजता है सेट कुकी जो है
वो आपका सर्वर सेंड करता है सबसे पहले जो
कुकी सेंड करते है वो सर्वर ही सेंड करता
है उसके अकॉर्डिंग फिर क्लाइंट उसको अपने
रिप्लाई में सेंड करता है ठीक है उस कुकी
के अकॉर्डिंग जो पॉलिसीज है तो हमने जैसे
ही वहां पे सेंड किया हमें कुकी मिला और
हम यहां पे डायरेक्टली लॉगइन हो गए हमने
लॉग इन किया नहीं हमने तो ए बी सी एक्स
वाई जड डाला था कुछ भी यूजर नेम पासवर्ड
डाल दिया था हमने बस कुकी चेंज किया सेट
कुकी में एंड वी गेट लॉग इन तो इस तरीके
से हमने क्या किया वी एक्सलेट हमने क्या
किया एक नॉर्मल से एक्सेसेस को हमने
अकाउंट टेकओवर में कन्वर्ट कर दिया इस
तरीके से आप यूजर की सेशन आईडी निकाल सकते
हैं सेशन आईडी निकाली एंड वो सेशन में आप
लॉगइन कर गए सेशन के अंदर लॉगइन कर ग सेशन
आईडी को रिप्लेस करके अटैकर की सेशन आईडी
जो होगी वो अपना सेशन आईडी रिप्लेस कर
देगा विक्टिम से एंड लॉग इन कुकीज निकाल
सकते हैं तो दिस इज
द एग्जांपल ऑफ अकाउंट टेक ओवर चेनिंग आपने
एक्सेसेस को अकाउंट टेकओवर में चेन कर
दिया यह समझ में आ
गया समझ में आई
है हां यह लाइव वेबसाइट पर ट्राई कीजिएगा
आप लोग क्योंकि लाइव वेबसाइट प उसी टाइम
मिल जाए इट्स नॉट इंपॉर्टेंट लाइव वेबसाइट
प उसी टाइम यह मिल भी जाए इट्स नॉट
इंपॉर्टेंट ऐसा भी जरूरी नहीं है तो लाइव
वेबसाइट प यह जरूरी अगर ऐसा मिल जाता है
फिर तो य बहुत बड़ी बात हो जाती है अगर
लाइव वेबसाइट प मिल जाती तो प्लीज ट्राई
ऑन लाइव वेबसाइट ठीक है ओके बबलू समझ में
आ
गया वेलकम राजा
अली
ठीक है वेलकम वेलकम लाइव वेबसाइट में कोई
सा भी ले लो ना भाई तुम लोग लाइव वेबसाइट
के पीछे क्यों पढ़ते हो मेरे को यह समझ
नहीं आता तुम लोग कांसेप्ट क्यों नहीं
समझते हो कांसेप्ट समझ में आया कि नहीं
पहले ये बताओ ऋषि दास यह मुझे बताइए और
बाकी जो यहां पे बबलू कुमार आप लोग या जो
भी लोग सोच रहे हैं मुझे यह बताइए आपको
कांसेप्ट समझ में आया कि नहीं आया कि आपको
क्या करना चाहिए अगर आपका पेलोड है वो
आपको कुकीज वैल्यू दे दे रहा है सेशन आईडी
दे दे रहा है व्हाट यू हैव टू डू नेक्स्ट
ये समझ में आ गया आपको क्लियर कि क्या
वहां पर करना है सिंपल
बताइए थैंक यू कलयुग हैकर हैकर
भाई समझ में नहीं
आया कुकीज किसकी जगह होगी भाई ड भाई कुकी
जो होगी ना सेट कुकी आप करोगे सेट कुकी
जैसे देखो क्या होता मैं आपको आपको दिखा
रहा हूं सिंपल मैं सिंपल सा फंडा दिखा रहा
हूं मैंने य पर लॉग आट
किया मैं साइन अप पर जाता हूं साइन अप पर
जाता हूं अब मैं यहां पर जब लॉग इन करूंगा
ना किसी वेब पोर्टल प आप लॉग इन करोगे
इसको मैं इंटरसेप्ट करके आपको दिखाता हूं
कैसे होता
है यहां पर चलते हैं मैं य पर टेस्ट पर
लॉगइन किया टेस्ट प लॉग इन किया एंड यहां
पर इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर देता हूं मैं यहां
पे लॉग इन करता हूं देखो ये नॉर्मल रियल
क्रेडेंशियल मैंने डाले हैं तो क्या होता
है फॉरवर्ड किया ये रिक्वेस्ट गई टेस्ट
पीए one web.com के एंड यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं कि यह कुकी वैल्यू सॉरी यह जो
पैरामीटर है ये गई य नेम टेस्ट एंड
पासवर्ड टेस्ट यह गई आपकी अब यहां पे आपको
एक कुकी वैल्यू दिख रही है लॉगिन इक्वल टू
टेस्ट परसेंट टू एफ टेस्ट ठीक है यह कुकी
वैल्यू आपको मिल गई लॉग इन यह आपको कुकी
वैल्यू मिल गई अब इसी कुकी वैल्यू को क्या
करेगा मैं कॉपी कर लेता हूं सर्वर जो है
ना सर्वर पहले भेजा हुआ होता है एक्चुअली
में सर्वर कुकी वैल्यू सेट करता है पहले
सर्वर सेट कुकी करता है देन क्लाइंट
रिक्वेस्ट में उस सेट कुकी के वैल्यू के
अकॉर्डिंग अपना रिप्लाई देती है तो ये
आपको जो रिप्लाई मिल रहा है ये क्लाइंट कर
रहा है बाद में करता है पहले सर्वर करता
है सर्वर क्या किया होगा सर्वर का क्या
सेट कुकी था तो राइट क्लिक करता हूं मैं
इसके रिस्पांस को मैं इंटरसेप्ट करता हूं
अब मैं देखो
फॉरवर्ड किया ये अभी भी ऊपर रिक्वेस्ट ही
है रिस्पांस वाला देखना है फॉरवर्ड
फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड ये देखो
रिस्पांस आया अब देखो इस रिस्पांस में
सर्वर ने क्या किया था सर्वर ने ये सेट
कुकी की हुई थी सवर ने क्या किया था ये
सेट कुकी किया हुआ था यानी कि इसने सेट
कुकी के अंदर में यह किया हुआ था कुकी सेट
की थी एंड इसी को क्लाइंट रिपीट रिस्पांस
में भेज रहा था रिक्वेस्ट हेडर के थ्रू
क्लाइंट के तरफ से बस हमें यही वाली कुक
सेट कुकी जो है आपको आपको सिंपल सेट कर
देनी है एज सिंपल एज दैट अब इसका मैं यहां
पे सिंपल इसको आपको मैं लाइव करके भी दिखा
देता हूं इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ किया
मैंने अब मैं यहां पे कहां पे हूं अब
मैं इस वाले पे firefox.exe
कम वाली हटा देता हूं फिलहाल के लिए
firefox.exe
है ना तो मैं फॉरवर्ड पर क्लिक करता हूं
ओके यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट गई फॉरवर्ड पर
क्लिक करता हूं अब मैं इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर
देता हूं अब तुम देखोगे तो यहां पर ये
लॉगिन नहीं होगा ओबवियसली क्योंकि हमने
रंग डाला था अब क्या करता हूं मैं ए बी सी
एक्स वाई जड मैंने फिर से गल ही डाला मैं
इसको यहां पर कैप्चर करता हूं लॉग इन करता
हूं अब मे पास यह जो आया है राइट क्लिक
करता हूं इंटरसेप्ट रिस्पांस करता हूं अब
मैं यहां पर फॉरवर्ड करता हूं यह
रिक्वेस्ट है इसके रिस्पांस को मैं
देखूंगा ये देखो यह रिस्प आया रिस्पांस
में क्या आ रहा है यू मस्ट लॉग इन इसका
मतलब है यह अभी लॉगइन नहीं हुआ है बट यह
बता रहा है कि आपको लॉगइन करना चाहिए
क्योंकि आप लॉगइन नहीं कर पा रहे क्योंकि
आपका पासवर्ड गलत है और यूजरनेम पासवर्ड
गलत है अब मैं क्या करूंगा यहां पे यहीं
पे मैं क्या करता हूं एक सेट कुकी का
पैरामीटर डाल देता हूं सेट कुकी लॉगिन जो
हमने कुकी निकाली थी एक्सेसेस से एंड इसको
मैं फॉरवर्ड करूंगा तो सर्वर अब बोलेगा
ब्राउजर को कि भैया ये कुकी अवेलेबल है
लॉग इन कर दो फॉरवर्ड किया इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ
किया यहां गए एंड यहां आप देखोगे कि यहां
पे लॉग आउट टेस्ट आ चुका है रीलोड आप
करोगे यहां पे तो ओबवियसली वी आर लॉग इन
अब आप लॉग इन पे आ चुके हैं प्रोफाइल पे
आप आएंगे यहां पे एंड यहां पे ये
एक्जिक्यूट प्रोफाइल ओपन हो गई एंड यहां
पे आपको लॉगइन करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ी यू
जस्ट लगड इन ट्स
इट समझ में आ
गया अब्दुल हादी सर मैं अभी आपकी सीएसपी
एंड एसओसी सीएसपी एंड सीओ आरएस वाली
वीडियो देख रहा था थैंक्स फॉर गिविंग सच
ग्रेट क्वालिटी वेलकम ब्रॉडी वेलकम अगर
आपको अच्छी लगती है यह क्लासेस तो आई
रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू शेयर द क्लासेस विथ
योर बॉडीज
linkedinsign.com
सॉरी लेट्स गो थू द
प्रोग्राम कुकीज सर्वर के साइड से सेट
होती है भाई देसी वॉइस सर्वर के साइड से
कुकी सेट होती
है ठीक
है हां अब चलिए यहां पे आते हैं कोई लाइव
टारगेट प यहां प आते हैं एक कोई टारगेट ले
लेते हैं कोई भी टारगेट चिया नेटवर्क ये
क्या है भाई चिया चिया नेट क्या हैय नाम
कैसा है ऐसा अच्छा नहीं लग रहा
नाम चिया कोर चिया डेस्कटॉप चिया
चिया लाइट स्पीड रेस्टोरेंट रेस्टोरेंट है
ये क्या बात है भाई लाइट स्पीड के
रेस्टोरेंट है
भाई भाई कितनी तेज आवाज आ रही है आप लोगों
की भी आवाज आ रही है क्या गाने की भाई कोई
ऐसा ना हो कि कॉपीराइट आ जाए यार गाने
भाई देखो इसलिए बोलता हूं थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर
करना चाहिए थोड़ा सा तो एक्सप्लोर आपको
करना चाहिए अभी मान लो आपको कुकीज का
बताया मैंने आपको ठीक है सेट कुकीज का
बताया कुकीज का बताया आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट
है कि आप एचटीटीपी हेडर्स के बारे में
जाके पढ़िए रिक्वेस्ट हेडर रिस्पांस हेडर
पढ़िए उसके अंदर आपको सारा कुछ मिल जाएगा
जो आप पूछ रहे हैं थोड़ा खुद से एक्सप्लोर
करो ना भाई एक्सप्लोर नहीं करोगे कैसे काम
चलेगा भाई कैसे
चलेगा कैसे नहीं
चलेगा है
ना
चलो अब यहां प आते हैं कोई एक वेबसाइट ले
लेते
[संगीत]
हैं हब स्पॉट पर आ लेते हैं हब स्पॉट पर
हब स्पॉट पर हब स्पॉट पर यह वाली हब स्पॉट
प आ
गए हप
कॉ ठीक है सो हप कॉ प आ जाते हैं य
प एंड एक्सेप्ट ल यहां पे यह वाली मान लो
यह आपकी यरल राइट यहां पर आपको आना है
कांटेक्ट सेल्स प आ जाते हैं लॉगिन प आ
जाते हैं कस्टमर सपोर्ट प आ जाते हैं
करियर प आ जाते हैं कांटेक्ट प आ जाते हैं
इन्वेस्टर रिलेशन मैनेजमेंट टीम आते आउटस
पे आ जाते हैं सारी चीजें भाई गेटर डेमो
पे आ जाते हैं स्टार्ट फ्री पे आ जाते हैं
जहां जो मिले जाते जाओ जाते
जाओ एक्सप्लोर तो खुद से करना पड़ेगा भाई
सब चीजें मैं नहीं
करूंगा खुद से एक्सप्लोर नहीं करोगे मजा
नहीं आएगा भाई बना दूंगा मैं टेंशन मत लो
वीडियो अगर चाहिए तो वो भी बना दूंगा भाई
चलो यहां पे आते हैं यहां पे कुछ है क्या
चैट चैट विद सेल्स बहुत बढ़िया चैट विद
सेल्स आ चुके भाई वेलकम टू द सेल्स टीम अब
यहां पे मैसेज आ गया यहां पे चलो बी एक्सस
खोज देते खोल देते यहां पे ये आ गया यहां
पे कॉपी डाला अपना चैट
में बाकी जो टैब्स है उनको बंद कर देते
हैं ताकि य कचड़ा कचड़ा टाइप ना लगे एकदम
से इसको बंद कर देते हैं इसको बंद कर इसको
बंद कर देते हैं एंड आई होप सो तो चैट प आ
चुका बहुत बढ़िया चैट आया मतलब मजा चैट
में आपने पेलो डाला एंड यहां प हमने एंटर
कर दिया ट्स इट
रिफ्रेश कर देते हैं हमने पेलो डाल दिया
है अच्छी बात है कुछ मिलता है तो हमें
यहां पर रिफ्लेक्शन आ जाएगी एक्स फायर्स प
आप आएंगे तो यहां प फायर्स आपको आ जाएंगे
ठीक है यहां प ईमेल आईडी पासवर्ड और य चीज
है यहां पर और कुछ यहां पर करना नहीं है
प्राइवेसी पॉलिसी तो इसको हटा देते हैं
यहां प यहां पर अब देखो यहां हम आ चुके
हैं अब यहां पर कुछ अगर मिलता है तो व्यू
प्रोफाइल यह क्या है व्यू स्टेटस पेज इस
पर आ जाते हैं इस पर आ जाते हैं डाउनलोड द
रिपोर्ट क्लिक करते हैं क्या है भाई ये
डायरेक्ट डाउनलोड हो रहा है क्या ठीक है
डायरेक्ट डाउनलोड हो रहा है सी ऑल ओपन
पोजीशंस ये अच्छी बात है सी ऑल ओपन
पोजीशंस यहां आते हैं आते आते आते यहां पे
आते हैं आते आते हैं यहां प कुछ और है
क्या कुछ भी नहीं है यह आ रहा सी ऑल ओपन
पोजीशंस ठीक है अच्छी बात है अप्लाई प
क्लिक कर देते हैं कुछ है क्या यहां पे
इनपुट का कुछ अप्लाई का ओहो क्या बात है
फर्स्ट नेम में डाल दिया हमने नास नेम में
डाल दिया ईमेल आईडी में डाल दिया हेलो @
h.com फोन नंबर में एक दोती च 5 6 7 8 9
10 डाल दिया एंड यहां पे रिज्यूम या सीवी
अटैच करने का ऑप्शन आ रहा है ये हमने अटैच
करने का ऑप्शन है यहां पे तो पीडीएफ डॉक
फॉर्मेट ले रहे हैं टी एक्सटी फॉर्मेट ले
रहे हैं सारा फॉर्मेट ले रहे हैं तो अब हम
क्या करते हैं भाई एक टेक्स्ट फॉर्मेट में
हमने क्या किया ब्लाइंड एक्सेस ये किया
यहां पे एंड यहां पे हमने ब्लाइंड एक्सेस
में यह वाली चीज डाल दी एंड यहां हमने
क्या किया यह किया यहां पे एंड यहां पे
हमने क्या किया इसको हमने पेलो डाल दिया
एंड यहां पे सेव कर दिया ये क्या है भाई
ब्लाइंड एक्सेस नाम से एक टेक्स्ट फाइल है
तो मैं मैं यहां प ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस वाली
फाइल सीवी में अटच अटैच कर देता हूं ठीक
है ये मैंने अटैच कर दिया य पे आई होप सो
यहां पे आ चुका लिंकन प्रोफाइल में वही
वाला डाल देता हूं डू यू हैव अ लीगल वर्क
और
नो वि नाउ र फीचर सपोर्ट यस एंड जेंडर मैं
यहां पर कर देता हूं द पोजीशन रिक्वायर यस
यस सब में यस करो जो भी आ रहा है यस यस
कुछ भी डाल दिया लोकेशन लोकेशन में भी डाल
दिया सबमिट योर एप्लीकेशन ठीक है नेटवर्क
फेल टू फेच ओके नेटवर्क एरर आ रहा है
सबमिट कर देते फिर से अगेन गड़बड़ी आ रही
है बेचारी की लिन प्रोफाइल में हम थोड़ा
सा छोड़ देते हैं यह रिक्वायर्ड नहीं है
तो व लीव दिस
फील्ड
ओके फर्स्ट नेम में यहां पे कुछ ज्यादा
बड़ा पेलोड हमने डाल दिया फर्स्ट नेम में
मैं डाल देता हूं यहां पे पेलोड को थोड़ा
सा छोटा वाला पेलो डाल देते हैं कोई बात
नहीं ये वाला पेलो उठा लेते हैं एंड यहां
पे हमने यहां डाल दिया सेल्स में डाल दिया
यहां
पे यहां डाल देते हैं सेल्स के बाद कहां
गई भाई वो हां यह डाल दिया लास्ट नेम में
ये डाल दिया एंड नाउ लेट्स
सबमिट अ ग्राफ कल एरर
[संगीत]
अनप्रोसैस्ड भाई ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस है भाई
मेरे सर्च बार में नहीं है देर लेट से आ
रहे हो क्या लेट से आ रहे हो क्या तुम ये
देखो गेट डेमो क्या बात है ओ हो हो ईमेल
आईडी डालो हेलो फोन नंबर में डाल दो कुछ
भी इंटर वैलिड ईमेल आईडी चल भाई वैलिड डाल
देते हैं चल भाई वैलिड डालते हैं देखो
वैलिड चाहिए भाई बोला करो यार कि वैलिड
ईमेल चाहिए बोला करो कि यह चाहिए वो चाहिए
क्या तुम लोग पॉप दे देते हो कंपनी नेम
में ये कोई कंपनी नेम में भी मैं डालूंगा
पेलोड डालूंगा मैं तो
अच्छा कंपनी में बड़ी वाली पेलो डालते
हैं लेट्स कॉपी टू द बड़ा
पेलोड देखते हैं वेबसाइट यूआरएल
एटीपी एप कलन goole.com ग से हूं हाउ मेनी
एंप्लॉई वर्क
देयर सब्सक्राइब टू हब स्पॉट मार्केटिंग
ब्लॉग नहीं चाहिए गेट अ फ्री डेमो कर दिया
गेट अ फ्री डेमो हब स्पॉट मार्केटिंग
सॉफ्टवेयर क्या बात है ये आ गया ट्रायल
स्टार्ट करने का मतलब चला गया भाई वो ठीक
है ना यहां पर ऑप्शन यहां पर और कुछ नहीं
है स्टार्ट 14 ट्रायल कुछ अदर यहां पर अगर
आ जाता है ईमेल एड्रेस डालने के लिए बोल र
वेरीफाई मुझे नहीं करना हटाओ खत्म यह वाली
चीज खत्म कर ली अगेन कस्टमर सपोर्ट चलो
कस्टमर सपोर्ट य राइट अ
मैसेज राइट अ
मैसेज
यस
ओके मैंने राइट एसेस में ये डाला एंड यह
डाल दिया भेज दिया इनको कोई बात नहीं य
डाल
द चैट वि सेल्स तो यह करते हैं यहां पर
फिर से फाइल अपलोड कर देंगे फाइल अपलोड का
ऑप्शन यह देंगे तो यह अपलोड का फाइल का
ऑप्शन दिया बला डाला यह डाला हर जगह सब
घुसाओ इसको भी एटर
मारो पूरा कवर करो भाई पूरा कवर करो देखा
हर जगह डालना है भाई यहां पर जहां एंट्री
मारनी है मार दो कांटेक्ट कस्टमर सपोर्ट ल
ग्लोबल नंबर कांटेक्ट सपोर्ट का कुछ है
क्या भाई अगर तुम इस तरीके से करोगे स्पैम
करोगे तो आपकी मैसेज को मैं टाइम आउट में
डाल दूंगा पुट यूजर इन टाइम आउट एंड यहां
पर 10 मिनट का टाइम आउट आपको कर देता हूं
ताकि आपके मैसेज चले
जाए ठीक है तो यहां हमने डाल दिया आप
स्पॉट कार पेज है यहां
हमने सेल्स वाली कर दी थी
एंड यहां कुछ है क्या ऑप्शन ऑप पास्ट
इंसिडेंट कुछ है क्या य पे नथिंग वाज देयर
कुछ कमेंट कुछ कमेंट करने का ऑप्शन नहीं
है यहां पर अच्छी बात है यहां पर हमने
देखा यहां भी कुछ हमें नहीं मिला यहां
हमें चैट सपोर्ट में मिल गया गेट फ्री
ट्रेनिंग गेट स्टार्टेड फ्री अच्छी बात है
और कुछ है यहां पर विजिट ह स्पॉट न्यूज
रूम कंपनी न्यूज ब्लॉग बहुत बढ़िया जो
मिले सब खोल
दोलो ठीक है यहां नीचे आ जाते
हैं कुछ और है यहां पर कुछ और है भाई इधर
देख लो यार इधर देख लो इधर देख लो डाउनलोड
का ऑप्शन आ रहा है ठीक है
नथिंग मच कंपनी की न्यूज है भाई न्यूज में
कुछ मिलेगा तो अच्छी बात है ईमेल एड्रेस
है यहां पर सब्सक्राइब करने का कोई बात
नहीं यह रहा आपके पेज का ओवरव्यू लर्न मोट
अबाउट
पस दीजिए ओहो यहां प मिल गई भाई गेट अ
फ्री डेमो वो तो अभी हमने किया था वही है
उसके यहां चेक करते रहो भाई पता नहीं कौन
सा फायर क्या आ जाए आपके पास है ना य भी
आपको मिला नहीं यहां पर सेम चीज है यहां
पे कांटेक्ट सपोर्ट वाली चीज है यहां पे
सो इफ देयर इज
सम कांटेक्ट
फॉर्म नहीं ट्स इट खत्म बस हो गया बस हो
गया गाइस
तो इस तरीके से बहुत कम लेट हो भाई 44
मिनट मोबाइल से बग बाउंट कैसे करें कुछ
नहीं कर सकते मोबाइल से भाई बग बाउंट नहीं
होती मोबाइल से वो आरडीपी वगैरह चला के
थोड़े बहुत कुछ टूल्स चला लोगे गिट पे
वगैरह कर लोगे वो अलग बात है बट सब कुछ
नहीं कर सकते लैपटॉप की जरूरत पड़ेगी आपको
ठीक है समझ में आ रहा तो दिस इज दिस वास अ
ब्लाइंड एक्सेस अब यहां पे थोड़ा सा हम
हैकर वन की कुछ रिपोर्ट्स पढ़ते हैं
ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस
हैकर
वन ने किया इसको ओपन कर लिया इसको ओपन कर
लिया इसको ओपन कर लिया इसको ओपन कर लिया
इसको ओपन कर
लिया रिपोर्ट्स जब तुम पढ़ते हो इससे
तुम्हारा कॉन्फिडेंस लेवल बढ़ता है और भी
बहुत सारी चीजें जो है तुम्हें जानने को
मिलता है अलग-अलग अप्रोचेबल जाते हैं कि
किस तरीके के
अप्रोचेबल रिपोर्ट जो है मैं आपसे रिकमेंड
करूंगा आपको कि आप हैकर वन के रिपोर्ट्स
उस पर्टिकुलर वलने एबिलिटीज की जरूर पढ़िए
उसको एनालाइज कीजिए और उस तरह की
अटेम्प्ट्स ट्राई कीजिए करने का आपका
माइंड और भी क्लियर हो जाएगा ठीक है जैसे
यहां पे पहला रिपोर्ट जो है ये हमने मिला
टॉप कोडर कांटेक्ट अस पे यहां पे इन्होंने
क्या किया ब्राउज टू द पेज दिस एंड फिल
आउट द कांटेक्ट फॉर्म एंड सबमिटिंग योर
ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस पेलोड फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट
नेम कंपनी एंड डिस्क्रिप्शन फील्ड सिंपल
इन्होंने क्या किया फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम
कंपनी में डिस्क्रिप्शन में पेलो डाल दिया
ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस का सबमिटिंग द फॉर्म एंड
हैव द एडमिन एक्सेस एंड एडमिन एक्सेस द
इंफॉर्मेशन ठीक है सबमिट किया अब बैक एंड
पे किसी एडमिन ने इंफॉर्मेशन को एक्सेस
किया जैसे मैंने आपको बताया था सेम चीज है
ठीक है दिस विल ट्रिगर एक्सेसेस इन द
एडमिन पैनल एंड अ नोटिफिकेशन टू द
एक्सेसेस हंटर सर्विस ये एडमिन पैनल साइड
में एक एक्सेसेस ट्रिगर करेगा आपका एंड वो
आपको कहां पे मिल जाएगा आपके जैसे आप आप
अभी एक्सएसएस यूज़ कर रहे हो तो आपको यहां
पे एक्सएसएस फायर्स वाली जो आपकी की अ
ऑप्शन है उसके अंदर आपको यहां पे मिल
जाएगा कोई भी एक्सेस अगर फायर होगा तो
यहां पे डायरेक्टली वो मिल जाएगा तो ये
सेम वैसा ही है जो हमने किया उसी तरीके का
कुछ है इनको यहां पे यह ट्रायक हुआ है
क्या हां यह ट्रायक हुआ है अच्छी बात है
यहां पे एंड दिस इज टा दिस इज ट्रायड ठीक
है ये ट्राय हुआ है एंड एक्सेप्ट भी हुआ
है इनका ठीक है सो
दैट्ची
क लाइव चट प सफर्स फ्रॉम क्रॉस सेट
स्क्रिप्टिंग लेबिलिटी एक् ठीक है ओके
यहां पे रेफरल यहां प इन्होने किया अब
यहां प देखो यहां प इन्होंने क्या किया
देखो ध्यान दो यहां पर इन्होंने यूजर
एजेंट यह किया कुकीज यह किया अब जब यह यह
कोड आप देख रहे हो यहां प यह कोड यहां पे
कोड है यहां प नीचे आओ नीचे आओ नीचे आओ
नीचे आओ नीचे की तरफ आ जाते हैं य नीचे की
तरफ अब यहां प इन्होने क्या किया पेलोड का
एक एक्सेसेस का पेलोड है ये इनका ये पेलोड
है ठीक है इन्होने य पेलोड लिया यहां पे
उसके बाद इन्होंने क्या
किया स्टेप्स में क्या लिखा इन्होंने
स्टेप्स तो कुछ बताए अच्छा रिपोर्ट नहीं
है ब ठीक है कोई बात नहीं इन्होंने क्लियर
नहीं बताया वहां पे ठीक
है द फॉलो इन्होने सिंपल सा कोई अपना जो
पेलोड है उसको यूज कर लिया है ट्स इट एंड
खत्म पेलो को यूज किया है उस पर्टिकुलर
पैरामीटर पे उस पर्टिकुलर पाथ प एंड उसके
बाद ट्राई किया है एंड अगर उनको मिल जाती
है वो अलर्ट मिल जाता है देन ही गट द पे
राइट ही गट द
स्क्रिप्ट अलॉट एंड ही गट हिज पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूटेड ट्स सिंपल ठीक है तो यहां पे
ये इनका ट्राय हुआ सेल्फ एक्सेसेस था ये
ओबवियसली इसलिए ज्यादा कुछ अच्छा रिपोर्ट
था नहीं यहां पे अब देखो यहां पे आया कि
ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस ऑन parcel.com यहां पे
एक ब्लाइंड एक्सेस है यहां पे कैसे माय
प्र यहां पे क्रिएट अ न्यू अकाउंट विथ अब
ये देखो इन्होंने क्या किया इस parcel.com
ठीक
है यह एक यूआरएल है क्या हुआ ये यूआरएल
गायब हो गई चलो यह एक पेज था इस पे इनको
700 $50 की बाउंट लगी है ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस
के लिए इन्होंने क्या किया इस पे एक
अकाउंट बनाया पेलोड के नाम से यह पेलोड के
नाम से अकाउंट बना लिया ठीक है अफेक्टेड
पेज इज app.tcs.com
पैनल प बैक एंड एक्यूट हो रहा है एंड आपको
अलर्ट मिल जा रहा है ए सिपल ठीक
है
सिंपल आपको समझ में आ
गया ओके बना दूंगा मैं वीडियोस तो लेकिन
आप लोग खुद से भी थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर कीजिएगा
ज्यादा बेटर रहेगा ठीक है तो यहां पर यह
एक रिपोर्ट इस तरीके की हो
गई
रिट अब यहां पर क्या किया इन्होने ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस वा फीडबैक फॉर्म देखो फीडबैक फॉर्म
से इन्होंने क्या किया आई फाउंड ब्लाइंड
एक्सेस विथ व्हिच इज ट्रिगर्ड ऑन द एडमिन
पैनल आई वाज ट्राइड टू ऐड विजिट्स ऑन द
इंस्टॉलेशन पेज ऑफ डिफॉल्ट थम ठीक है
व्हेन द इंस्टॉलेशन वाज डन आई सॉ अ
क्वेश्चन लाइक आर यू हैप्पी विथ हाउ
एवरीथिंग लुक्स आई क्लिक्ड द नो प्लीज
रिमूव ऑल विजिट्स बटन एंड देन फीडबैक
फॉर्म अराइव्स ठीक है आई सबमिटेड माय
ब्लाइंड एक्सेस पेलोड फीडबैक फॉर्म में
ब्लाइंड डाला इ ट्रिगर आफ इन 20 टू 30
मिनट्स 20 से 30 मिनट में वो ट्रिगर हुआ
सोचिए तो कुछ भी हो सकता है भाई बस इसको
ना चेक करते रहना है इस को रीलोड करना है
एक्सस फ पर जाना है चेक करते रहिए कुछ
शायद फगर हो जाए शायद आ जाए तो यहां क्या
कि ये शफाई की वेबसाइट प आप जाइए लॉगिन
क्रेडेंशियल कीजिए ऐड विजिट कीजिए यहां पे
फीडबैक वाली प जाइए एंड यहां पे पेलोड
अपना डाल दीजिए एंड वेट कीजिए अपने ट्रिगर
का ट्स इट ये एक ऑफर आ गई आपकी ठीक है
ब्लाइंड एक्सेस इन एडमिन पैनल फॉर
रिव्यूइंग कमेंट्स $50 मिले भाई इनको 2017
की ये चीज है तो इन्होंने क्या किया
स्टेप्स देख लेते हैं नहीं
है इन्होंने क्या किया देखो एक चीज मैं
तुमको दिखा देता हूं शायद यहां दिख
जाएगी यहां पे मलेशियन पेलोड वास सबमिटेड
एट इतना इस पे यहां पे यहां पे क्या है
डिस्कवर द इट इ पॉसिबल टू एक्सप्लोइट अ
ब्लाइंड एक् वटी अंडर द माउथ ऑफ द टू
रॉकस्टार सेक्शन वाइल प्रोवाइड फीडबैक ये
फीडबैक देते टाइम इन्होंने किया द रिजल्ट
इज एक्सेस वलने बिलिटी बीइंग एक्सप्लोइटेड
ऑन एन इंटरनल रॉकस्टार गेम डोमेन द वे इट
इज वर्क वाज दैट अटैकर वुड सबमिट अ मालिश
एक्सेस पेलोड इन एन इनपुट फील्ड बट कैन
नॉट रियली सी इट बीइंग एक्सप्लोइटेड
ओबवियसली वही चीज है और कुछ नहीं ठीक है
देयर वाज नो सोशल इंजीनियर इवॉल्वड
इन्होंने ये चीज किया ये ट्रैक भी हुई है
यहां पे $500 की बाउंट मिली है फिर $150
की बाउंट मिली है बोनस के तौर पे एंड
दैट्ची लगी है ये 2020 का रिपोर्ट है एंड
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे ये एक शानदार
रिपोर्ट है यहां पे इन्होंने रिपोर्ट किया
है है एंड आप देख सक देखिए यहां
पे दे फर्स्ट शो इट लिटिल मैस लेट मी
एक्सप्लेन आई फाउंड अ एक्सेस व्हेन आई सी
अ सेंड द इमेज इन द सपोर्ट चैट एंड चेंज द
इमेज नेम टू सम स्क्रिप्ट नेम चेंज इमेज
का ठीक है द सीएसआर पार्ट यू कैन इग्नोर
सिंस द हैकर कैन इंजेक्ट एक्सेस इन द
सपोर्ट देन सेंड अ मैसेज विद एक्सेस इमेज
टू एवरी यूजर या इट इज अ मैसिव एक्सटेंस
ऑफ यूजर शुड बी अफेक्टेड यह आपको दिख रहा
है यहां पे सिंपल क्या है स्टेप्स ू रि
प्रोड्यूस यूज अ प्रॉक्सी लाइक बॉब शूट
एंड टर्न इंटरसेप्ट ऑन अपलोड अ फाइल टू द
सपोर्ट चार्ट सपोर्ट चार्ट का यहां पे
फाइल था उसको सपोर्ट चार्ट में फाइल अपलोड
की चेंज द फाइल नेम टू ये मतलब ये एक
पेलोड
है इन्होंने एक पेलोड का नेम फाइल नेम में
डाल
दिया ये एक यहां पे पेलोड यहां पे डाल दी
ठीक है उसके बाद सेंड कर दिया ओपन द चैट
सपोर्ट एंड एक्सेसेस विल एक्टिवेट एंड
एक्सेस एक्टिवेट हो जाएगा स है सिंपल तो
एक इन्होंने इस तरीके का कुछ कुछ किया है
एंड यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं यहां प नीचे
आओगे तो यहां पर शायद ट्रैग हो जाएगा
ट्रैग हुआ होगा ट्रैग हुआ है यहां पे एंड
यहां प $1000 की बाउंट इनको लग गई है सीएस
मनी सीएस मनी कोई प्रोग्राम है उनको
इन्होंने रिपोर्ट किया है रिपोर्टेड टू
सीएस मनी ट्स इट 000 लगी है भाई अभी
रिसेंट की बात है सोचो ट्स इट
ग्रेट यहां पे 2021 की बात है डिजिटल ओसन
को यहां पर रिपोर्ट किया गया भैया यहां
बाउंट लगी है कि नहीं लगी है पहले ये देख
लेते हैं
इनफॉर्मेटिव क्लोज हुआ है नाइस ई बट कोई
बात नहीं चलेगा
य एक्सेस हंटर एंड यह शायद एक्सस हंटर
वाली ही यूज हो रही है मेरे ख्याल
से एक्सस हंटर वाली यूज हुई है सो ब्लाइंड
डिस्क डिजिटल ओसन पार्टनर एडमिन पैनल
डैशबोर्ड र अटकर कैन रन आर्बिट
जावास्क्रिप्ट को ठीक है
पार्टन रिक्वेस्ट एंड अकाउंट इस पर जाते
हैं
एंड यहां पे करते हैं
सॉरी बिकम अ पार्टनर या रिक्वेस्ट एंड
अकाउंट पे होगा तो यहां पे कुछ ऑप्शन था
क्या ऐसा कुछ ठीक है कोई बात नहीं क्लिक
ऑन रिक्वेस्ट एंड अकाउंट फील अ फीड अ
वैलिड ईमेल एड्रेस एंड इंस्टेंट एक्सेस
हंटर पेलोड एट फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम
टेक्स्ट फील्ड एंड एक्सेसेस विल बी
एग्जीक्यूटेड व्हेन द एडमिन डैशबोर्ड यूजर
विल गो इन एंड सी द अकाउंट रिक्वेस्ट ठीक
है इन्होंने ये काम किया इन्होंने ये
पेलोड यहां पे लगाया यहां पे इन्होंने ये
जो पेलोड पॉप अप हुआ था उसका यहां पे
डिटेल लगा दिया यह कुछ इस तरीके का यहां
पे अ डिटेल जो है वो आ चुका
है कुछ इस तरीके
के ये इन्होंने डिटेल दिया नोट दैट द
पेलोड ज एग्जीक्यूटेड अटक यहां पे इंपैक्ट
क्या होता है इनका ये देखिए एन अटैकर वुड
बी एबल टू रन आर्बिट्री जावास्क्रिप्ट कोड
वि एट विजिटर इंड उसके बाद अटैकर कैन
स्टील द कुकीज ऑफ द एडमिन यूजर एंड टेक
ओवर द एडमिन पैनल बिकॉज ड्यू टू द एब्सेंट
ऑफ एसटीपी ओनली कुकी वैल्यू फ्लैग द
एक्सेस पलट कैन डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्ट विद द
डॉम एंड गेट सेशन कुकीज जिससे कि आप
बेसिकली अकाउंट लॉगइन कर सकते हैं अब
देखिए इन्होंने क्या किया किया देखो इसको
देखो नीले
अंबर कोई बात नहीं देखते
हैं कोई बात नहीं अब बैकग्राउंड को कुछ कर
नहीं सकते हैं अगर कुछ ऐसा कॉपीराइट का
इशू आता है तो वी विल सी दैट हम उसको
रिमूव कर लेंगे कॉपीराइट इशू आएगा तो ठीक
है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है राइट मैं ट्राई
करूंगा इसको कुछ करने का बैकग्राउंड में आ
रही है साउंड तो ज्यादा कुछ प्रॉब्लम नहीं
आनी चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से बट देख लेते हैं
द फॉलो हाई फॉलो अप विद द फॉलोइंग अपडेट्स
थैंक यू फॉर द सबमिशन रिप क रिव्यूड आई
हैव नॉट हैड एनी एक्सेसेस फायर्स इन माय
अकाउंट यह इन्होंने बोला यहां पे अ लाइक
जो कंपनी का है अ इट आ एम इन माय अकाउंट
इज ऑलमोस्ट फुली वर्किंग डज नॉट लुक लाइक
इट्स बीन रिव्यूड यट आई एम गोइंग टू
फॉरवर्ड दिस टू द इंटरनल टीम हाय यहां पे
सर थैंक्स फॉर टेकिंग टाइम टू लक इन आई एम
नॉट श्योर व्हिच ईमेल एड्रेस आई यूज्ड
वाइल सबमिटिंग द रिक्वेस्ट बट आई रिमेंबर
द अ नेम एज शे तो छाया सव डट ऐसा कुछ करके
यहां पे कुछ आया सर एनी अपडेट्स नीट वास
देयर वाज नो इंटरेक्शन सो फार विथ माय
एक्सेस विथ माय एक्सेस हंटर एंड इट्स
अनक्लियर व्हाई आर यू श्योर द एक्सेस वा
टिकट फ्रॉम द इनपुट यू स्पेसिफाइड यहां पे
न्यू किया यहां पे एंड यहां पे यहां पे ये
इन्होंने इनफॉर्मेटिव क्लोज कर दिया आई है
ट्राइड मल्टीपल एंड रिप्लिकेट दिस इशू एंड
द इंजेक्शन इज नॉट पॉसिबल अनलेस अ वैलिड
पीसी कैन बी शेयर्ड वी कैन नॉट वैलिडेट द
इशू ठीक है यहां पे फिर यहां पे नीचे आया
यहां पे यहां पे यह चीज करी इन्होंने यहां
पे नीचे आया नीचे आया यहां पे रिओपन इनका
एक वापस से ओपन हुआ है जो है यह रिपोर्ट
जो है वापस से रिओपन किया गया एंड यहां पे
वापस से इसने बताया सरा चीज आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे टोटल अगेन ये इनफॉर्मेटिव
क्लोज हुआ है ठीक है
दैट्ची वेंडर एंड आवर कांट्रैक्ट विद देम
हैज एंडेड मतलब इनका कांट्रैक्ट भी एंड हो
चुका है दस वी डू नॉट हैव एक्सेस टू द
एडमिन पेज टू वेरीफाई दिस इशू एंड द साइट
विल बी टेकन डाउन शॉर्टली मतलब ओबवियसली
इनका सच ऐसा भी होता है कांट्रैक्ट खत्म
हो चुका है तो अब ये रिपोर्ट नहीं करेंगे
बस दैट्ची हो गई तो इस तरीके से भी अ ये
काम करता है रिपोर्ट्स को आपको पढ़ना
पड़ता है रिपोर्ट जितना आप पढ़ेंगे उतना
ही आपको नॉलेज आपकी नॉलेज बढ़ेगी एंड यहां
पे आप देख सकते हैं नहम सेख ने रिपोर्ट
किया यहां पे एंड ये रिपोर्ट कब हुई थी
2020 में हुई थी द पेज लोकेटेड एट दिस
सफर्स फ्रॉम अ क्रॉस सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग
लेबिलिटी व्हेन अ यूजर हैज सेट देयर होस्ट
नेम ऑन द मशीन टू एन एक्सेसेस
पेलोड ठीक है आईपी यहां पे रेफरल डाला
यहां पे ये सारी चीज डाली इंपैक्ट यहां पे
कुछ बताया नहीं इंपैक्ट में ठीक है नाइस
फाइंड ंग व विल गेट दिस एक्सलेटर टू द
ट्रैग हो चुका है ये अच्छी बात है थैंक्स
नेम सेक ओन आ टेकिंग फ्रॉम हियर लल द
फर्स्ट आई हर्ड सा एफ द रिपोर्ट सबमिटेड
टू अस हैकर वन एंप्लॉई द रिपोर्ट वास
सबमिटेड टू अस बाय अ हैकर वन एंप्लॉई अ वच
आर एक्सक्लूडेड फ्रॉम बाउंटीज इन आवर बग
बाउंट प्रोग्राम तो एंप्लॉई ने रिपोर्ट
किया ओबवियसली तो ये बाउंट एक्सक्लूडेड है
तो ये कुछ इस तरीके से जो है आप रिपोर्ट्स
को पढ़ सकते हैं अलग-अलग रिपोर्ट्स
पढ़ेंगे तो आपको अलग-अलग तरह की जानकारी
अलग-अलग तरह का माइंडसेट आपका क्रिएट होगा
एक अलग तरीके का माइंडसेट जब क्रिएट होगा
ना तो आप अलग-अलग वनबिल को अलग-अलग तरीके
से आप उसको रिपोर्ट करेंगे ट्राई करेंगे
फाइंड करने का एंड आपके चांसेस वहां पे
बढ़ते जाते हैं इसलिए रिपोर्ट करना इज
वेरी वेरी रिपोर्ट पढ़ना इज वेरी वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट बहुत ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट है
आपको भले लग रहा हो रिपोर्ट क्या ही होगा
क्या ही होगा उससे बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट
है भाई याद रखिएगा वेरी वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट
तो हमने बेसिक आज की क्लास में क्या देखा
सो हमने बेसिकली आज हमने ब्लाइंड एक्सेस
के बारे में पढ़ा यहां पे हमने ऑनलाइन टूल
बीएक हंटर का यूज किया बॉब कोलैबोरेटर के
थ्रू देखा एक्सप्रेस हटर के बारे में
मैंने आपको बताया यहां प मैंने बताया कि
आपको अलग-अलग तरह पे अलग-अलग जगहो प आप
कैसे डाल के एंड ये चीजें कर सकते हैं
ब्लाइंड एक्सेस फाइंड कर सकते हैं हमने
देखा कि यहां पे ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस को कैसे
आप चेन अप कर सकते हैं अकाउंट टेकओवर
लेबिलिटी में या कोई और लेबिलिटी में यहां
पे कांसेप्ट में आपको बताने आया हूं मैं
आपको गाइड करता हूं ठीक है मैं आपको स्पून
फीडिंग नहीं करता याद रखिएगा वो कभी मैं
करता नहीं हूं मेरी आदत भी नहीं है गाइड
का मतलब यहां पे क्या है सिंपल मैं आपको
बताऊंगा आपके पास खाना पड़ा हुआ है अब मैं
आपको मान लो आपके पास कोई अ फॉरेन इटालियन
डिश पड़ी हुई है अब मैं आपको यह डिश पड़ी
हुई है अब मैं आपको बता दूंगा कि यह वाली
फॉक यूज़ करो यह वाली चीज यूज करो यह वाली
अ जो अ पर्टिकुलर एक बाउल है उसको उसमें
उस तरीके से डालना और यह वाली फॉक के साथ
उसको ऐसे खाना यह वाली स्टिक को यूज करना
मैंने ये चीज आपको बता दी अब उसको खाना आप
ही को है अब मैं आपको लाके खिला नहीं सकता
वो इंपॉसिबल है वो मेरे से नहीं होता वो
क्योंकि आपको कांसेप्ट सीखना है आपको बग
बाउंटीज सीखना है पहले वो कांसेप्ट
सिखाऊंगा मैं आपको वो तरीके बता दूंगा
खाना खुद को ही है ठीक है खुद को ही मजा
आएगा समझ में आ
गया गॉट इट य चलिए आप सबको यह तो आपको
क्लियर समझ में आ गया होगा राइट चलिए तो
बस आई होप कि आपका कांसेप्ट ब्लाइंड
एक्सेसेस को लेके एक्सेसेस को लेके क्लियर
हो चुका है सब कुछ एक्सेसेस के ऊपर आप
बढ़िया से थोड़ा और एक्सप्लोर करेंगे तो
आपको और भी बहुत कुछ जानने सीखने को
मिलेगा मैं आपको ये नहीं बोल रहा सिर्फ
इतना ही होता है एक्सेसेस आपसे मैं
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि आप अपने जो भी बग
बाउटी में टॉपिक जो भी पढ़ रहे हैं सीख
रहे हैं कर रहे हैं व्हाट एवर आप अपने
करते हैं कुछ एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं और हमें
टैक करते हैं रियली वी फील सो ग्रेट कि
हमारे स्टूडेंट्स हैं या जो भी
प्रोफेशनल्स हैं वो ऐसा कर रहे हैं एंड दे
आर गेटिंग समथिंग तो यह काम आप प्लीज कर
दीजिएगा इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट बहुत अच्छा लगता
है यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं एक्टिविटी पे
मैं जाता हूं यहां पे हमारे जो स्टूडेंट्स
हैं ऑलरेडी वो टैग्स करते रहते हैं बाकी
लोग जो भी चीजें करते हैं वो टैग्स करते
हैं एंड वी गेट अ लॉट लॉट ऑफ ग्रेट
रिव्यूज ऑन दिस बग बाउंट कोर्स सो आई होप
आपको समझ में आ गया हो गाइ एंड आई थिंक कि
अ आज की क्लास के लिए बस इतना ही काफी है
आज की क्लास के लिए एंड अगर आपको मजा आया
तो लाइक ठोकते हुए जाना जब जाना तो एकदम
लाइक ठोकते हुए जाओ चैनल चैनल पे एंड
वीडियो स्पेस प और अपने दोस्तों को भी
शेयर कर देना उसके बाद ताकि सब तक यह
कोर्स पहुंचे मैं चाहता हूं सारे इंफो से
कम्युनिटी बग बांटी कम्युनिटी तक यह कोर्स
पहुंचे कि भैया यह कोर्स इतना शानदार कैसे
हो सकता है फ्री में और भाई रहेगा शानदार
मजेदार धमाकेदार रहेगा हमेशा रहेगा याद
रखिएगा
ठीक है प्रैक्टिकल ही होता है भाई सब कुछ
कहां रहते हो सारा कुछ तो प्रैक्टिकली
दिखा रहा हूं क्या बोलते हो यार तुम लोग
चलो ठीक
है ओके सारी कुछ आएंगी सारी कुछ आएंगी ओके
तो चलिए कैसा लगा आज मतलब सीखा एक्सेस के
बारे में मजा आया ब्लाइंड एक्सेसेस अब
ट्राई करो जाके एक्सप्लोर करो जाओ फोर
डालो अब घुसाओ अब एक्सेस के पेलो चारों
तरह जगह में घुसाते जाओ अलग-अलग तरह के
एक्सेस के पेट्स को घुसाओ अलग-अलग एक ही
फॉर्म सबमिट फॉर्म में डिफरेंट पेट्स को
यूज करो ताकि एक पेलोड अगर एग्जीक्यूट ना
हो तो दूसरा पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट हो जाए भाई
क्या दिक्कत है एक पेलोड ना हो दूसरा
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाए और फिर अपना ये एक्सस
फायर्स प आके चेक आउट करते रहो शायद कुछ
फायर मिल जाए कुछ कुछ भी मिल जाए राइट ठीक
है सो आई होप यू एंजॉयड द क्लास यू लर्न
समथिंग एंड आगे भी आप सीखते जाएंगे एंड
आगे भी आपको मजा आता जाएगा ठीक है तो बस
आज के सेशन के लिए इतना
ही एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में कुछ नए
टॉपिक कुछ नया इंटरेस्टिंग लेके बग
बाउंटीज के अंदर काफी मजा आने वाला है दो
दिनों का गैप रखते हैं एटलीस्ट एंड देन
मिलते हैं ठीक है अगर आप लोग इसी तरीके से
सपोर्ट करते रहोगे एंड इतनी प्रेजेंस
रखोगे अच्छी खासी तो ओबवियसली आपको
क्वालिटी कंटेंट मिलती जाएगी बट अगर आप
लोग ही हार मान जाओगे ना प्रेजेंस नहीं
रखोगे आप लोग ही नहीं उस टाइप से कर पाओगे
तो फिर मेरा भी तो यार इंटरेस्ट कम हो
जाएगा ना खुद सोचो ना यार है ना मजा चलिए
वेलकम वेलकम
वेलकम सर मेरे बोट्स चालू हैं होने वाले
हैं मुझे साइबर सिक्योरिटी फील्ड में जाना
है सो आपको गाइडेंस चाहिए बोट्स को ध्यान
दो बोट्स पे ध्यान दो बोर्ड्स को इग्नोर
मत करो बोट्स में अच्छे नंबर्स लाओ मैं य
बोलूंगा ठीक है चलिए गुड नाइट
सबको ओके एंड थैंक यू फॉर जॉइनिंग हैव अ
गुड नाइट शेयर कर दीजिए वीडियो को एंड
लाइक ठोक
जाइएगा चलिए बाय
बाय